et l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau nos reporters
également sur le terrain voici les
grands titres de l'actualité de ce mardi
14 janvier
vladimir poutine désigne le patron du
fisc russe michail michaud sting comme
un nouveau premier ministre une
nomination après l'annoncé surprise de
la démission du gouvernement d'une
maîtrise medvedev une demande de
changement hébergé au sein de la société
selon le président russe offre à san
juan y appelle à l'unité nationale le
président iranien est sous pression des
protestataires depuis le crash du boeing
crémière battu par erreur des milliers
d'ukrainiens ont une nouvelle fois
manifesté leur indignation hier au plan
diplomatique paris londres et berlin
déclenché une procédure pour contraindre
téhéran à respecter ses engagements
nucléaires
[Musique]
emmanuel macron renoue avec la tradition
il a présenté aujourd'hui ses voeux à la
presse à l'elysée le chef de l'état a
évoqué plusieurs sujets durant cette
locution protection des sources sécurité
des journalistes ou bien encore réforme
de l'audiovisuel public émailleront qui
promet de continuer à expliquer et
concertée la réforme des retraites
sixième semaine de mobilisation un
rassemblement de fonctionnaires a eu
lieu aujourd'hui devant le ministère des
finances manifestation également de la
police scientifique ils sont les
bienvenus mais à quel prix ici le prince
harry et son épouse mégane s'installer
au québec ce ne serait pas aux frais des
contribuables précisé prévient surtout
le chef du parti politique
indépendantiste
lundi dernier la reine elizabeth a en
tout cas accepté une période de
transition lors de laquelle le couple
royal pourra vivre au pays
une partie de l'année
[Musique]
en russie mirel michaud skins a donc
accepté le poste de premier ministre
après la démission du gouvernement de
mitry medvedev avec la démission de
toute son équipe
ce dernier a dit vouloir donner au
président les moyens de prendre toutes
les mesures qui s'imposent
vladimir poutine a remercié et dmitri
medvedev pour son travail on retrouve en
direct sur place à moscou notre
correspondant antoine claireaux antoine
bonsoir on sait désormais qui est le
nouveau premier ministre un oui il ne
reste qu'à la douma a validé cette
nomination ce qui ne devrait être qu'une
formalité ce sera donc mirail michou
steen qui va succéder à vladimir trimer
de vnf au titre de premier ministre âgé
de 54 ans et jusque là inconnu du grand
public il était depuis 2010 à la tête du
du la tête pardon du service fédéral des
impôts en russie cette nomination
intervient après une journée riche en
rebondissements
lors de son adresse annuelle devant
l'assemblée fédérale dans la matinée
vladimir poutine a proposé plusieurs
amendements plusieurs réformes à la
constitution des réformes qui donnerait
davantage de pouvoirs au parlement juste
après son discours face à cette
assemblée fédérale
le premier ministre dimitri medvedev
s'est entretenu avec le président russe
et à la sortie de cette rencontre le
premier ministre dimitri medvedev a
présenté la démission de son
gouvernement écouter
aussi chers collègues vous avez tous été
témoins du message du président de la
fédération de russie vladimir
vladimirovitch en tant que président a
non seulement fixer les priorités du
travail dans notre pays pour l'année à
venir mais a également décrit un certain
nombre de changements fondamentaux et
dans la constitution de la fédération de
russie elle ces changements lorsqu'ils
seront adoptées et selon toute
probabilité cela se fera après une
discussion comme cela a été dit
apporteront des modifications
importantes non seulement un certain
nombre d'articles de la constitution
mais aussi dans l' équilibre du pouvoir
dans son ensemble au sein du pouvoir
exécutif pouvoir législatif et pouvoir
judiciaire dans ce contexte il est
évident que nous en tant que
gouvernement de la fédération de russie
devons donner au président de notre pays
la possibilité de prendre toutes les
décisions nécessaires à cet effet et
dans ces conditions je pense qu'il
serait juste que conformément à
l'article 117 de la constitution de la
fédération de russie
le gouvernement de la fédération de
russie dans sa composition actuelle
démissionne je remercie bien entendu
ceux qui ont participé au travail du
gouvernement dans cette composition et
bien sûr les décisions suivantes seront
prises par le président du pays reste
en réponse vladimir poutine a dit
prendre acte de cette décision et
remercié le premier ministre sortant
ainsi que tous ses ministres pour tous
leurs efforts écouter pour ma part je
voudrais aussi vous remercier pour tout
ce qui a été fait durant cette étape de
notre travail commun je voudrais
exprimer ma satisfaction quant aux
résultats obtenus
bien sûr tout n'a pas réussi mais il
n'est jamais possible de tout faire dans
son intégralité
j'espère que nous verrons prochainement
je rencontrerai chacun d'entre vous et
vous demande d'assumer vos fonctions
dans leur intégralité jusqu'à la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
[Musique]
entre la entre la promesse de réformes
constitutionnelles la démission soudaine
du gouvernement et la nomination tout
aussi rapide d'un nouveau premier
ministre
c'est donc une nouvelle page du pouvoir
exécutif qui s'ouvre en russie merci
antoine claireaux en direct depuis
moscou
il annonce surprise après donc le
discours annuel du chef de l'état devant
les députés et sénateurs russes
allocution devant l'assemblée fédérale
qui réunit les deux chambres du
parlement au menu la question de la
démographie et la volonté de mettre en
place une nouvelle politique familiale
et des mérites il a également proposé
une série de réformes constitutionnelles
soumises à référendum sur le sujet des
sénateurs
poutine réfléchir au système politique
qui va fonctionner en russie pendant les
dernières années 2
de sa présidence et après sa présidence
et je pense qu'il est venu à la
conclusion que il faut procéder une ce
que j'appellerais une démocratisation du
pouvoir présidentiel en russie
ça ne veut pas dire que le président va
être destitué de ses pouvoirs et devenir
une personne elle était honoraires comme
dans quelques pays acp
le président on va toujours conservé 2
prérogatives assez importante mais il
doit compter plus avec le parlement et
le gouvernement parce que d'après les
propositions de monsieur poutine
le parlement va décider qui sera le
premier ministre et qui seront et quelle
sera la formation du cabinet donc ça
sera un système mélanger très dmitri
medvedev après sa démission s'est vu
proposer le poste de vice-président du
conseil de sécurité de russie qu'il a
d'ailleurs accepté sa carrière avait
décollé quand il fut propulsé à la
présidence en 2008 son portrait signé
guilhem herbert fidèle parmi les fidèles
ancien juriste dmitri medvedev est
arrivé sur le devant de la scène
politique en 2005 comme vice premier
ministre avant d'être propulsé président
en 2008 à seulement 42 ans succédant
ainsi à vladimir poutine
leur histoire commune débute dans les
années 90 à la mairie de saint
pétersbourg en 1999
medvedev intègre l'équipe de vladimir
poutine qui brigue alors la présidence
pour prendre la suite de boris eltsine
poutine et lui medvedev est d'abord
nommé à la tête de l'administration
présidentielle avant de prendre la
direction de gazprom en juin 2002 c'est
d'ailleurs lui qui est à l'origine du
gazoduc sous marin reliant directement
la russie à l'europe de l'ouest en
évitant les états baltes et la pologne
président de 2008 à 2012 il aura
maintenu la ligne politique établie par
vladimir poutine avant de lui laisser la
main
le 8 mai 2012 il est nommé président du
gouvernement russe après son mandat à la
tête de la fédération de russie
réélu en 2018 il est la personne à avoir
occupé le plus longtemps le poste de
chef du gouvernement depuis 1991
ce 15 janvier donc il présente sa
démission et celle de son gouvernement à
vladimir poutine remercié pour son
action par le président dimitri medvedev
devrait désormais devenir vice président
du conseil de sécurité russe pour en
parler nous sommes avec gen berg ancien
ambassadeur de france et essayer
bonsoir gène béhague mais ce bon choix
en irak sur rt france alors cette
démission du gouvernement qui est tombée
cet après midi une vraie surprise pour
vous aussi le grand connaisseur de
bridiers sûr ça a été inattendue pour
tout le monde
peut-être pas les intéresser bien sûr
certains disaient avec quelques rumeurs
bon c'est vrai que le poste de medvedev
était déjà je dirais pas sur un siège
éjectable mais déjà depuis deux trois
ans disais qu'un jour ça dure tellement
de temps il partira mais finalement est
pas parti et là effectivement il ya eu
une espèce d'accélération d'histoire
parce qu'il faut bien dire c'est une
véritable accélération de l'histoire
c'est tanière et bien justement il a dit
vladimir poutine la russie maintenant
est assez mûr il a dit c'est intéressant
il n'y a plus de coup d'état
le caucase il ya plus d'insurrection
elle est mûre pour entamer une plus
grande progression vers une démocratie
c'était intéressant donc pour moi c'est
une véritable étape il y avait un
pouvoir présidentiel fort qui cumulait
tous les pouvoirs c'est la comptine en
93 et l'a dit maintenant il faut
relâcher un petit peu il faut donner
plus de pouvoirs à la douma et ce
pouvoir il va changer certains articles
on reviendra sur le mandat présidentiel
maintenant la douma aura pour
responsabilité de voter
le choix du produit ni c'est elle qui va
de thé alors faut savoir si une fois le
premier votée elle pourra entériner
chaque membre du gouvernement c'est des
détails qu'on verra dans les mois à
venir ce avait discuté mais là vraiment
la douma qui était un peu de gens
d'enregistrement va devenir un organe
plus politique
alors évidemment pour l'instant il n'y a
aucun souci pour le pouvoir
est-ce qu'ils ont de majorité mais tout
de même c'est quand même plus qu'une
nuance à montrent que la russie
maintenant elle est beaucoup plus stable
plus assuré et poutine prépare
finalement l'après poutine pour entrer
dans l'histoire comme l'homme qui a
stabilisé la russie qu'il a unifié et
qui lui fait progresser dont le nom dans
une voie démocratique à la russe bien
sûr
et donc qui devrait couper à mon sens
beaucoup de critiques en disant c'est un
régime autocratique présidentielle donc
c'est pour moi un pas important et que
je qualifierais d'historique
alors on n'entend évidemment les
critiques certainement de certains
observateurs
toujours prompte à critiquer la russie
ouais il prépare la près peut-être pour
s'y remettre encore une fois quelle est
notre rêve il est beau là aussi il faut
être très prudent de 24 c'est encore
long jusqu'à 30 mm plus quatre ans parce
que c'est les élections ont lieu en mai
2000 alors il veut avoir les mains
libres et il veut avoir le choix de la
décision sur son successeur est ce qu'il
se représente pas lui-même ou pas
normalement on verra c'est ce qui les
renverra alors garé oui alors il ya un
article
j'ai regardé je vais essayer l'article
81 ligne la iii qui dit qu'il en avait
parlé des sanctionnés ou convivialité
gentiment et a dit peut-être qu'il
faudrait changer cet article certes le
président ne peut pas faire plus de deux
mandats et demande à ses 2 c'est pas
successifs
donc on verra alors évidemment depuis
très longtemps des bauges d'état de deux
scénarios il pourrait être la
biélorussie pourrait s'allier la russie
serait président le biélorussie et la
russie mais pour l'instant ça marche pas
mais disons que simplement il veut
élargir il veut montrer qu'il n'y a pas
que mes vnf bon medef le suit depuis
très longtemps il a été son chef de
cabinet à saint pétersbourg ou 90 vous
l'avez rappelé il a été vice premier
ministre entend déjà ans qu on se
souvient en 2007 avant d'être peu près
son successeur pour l'instant il est
il a encore les mains libres et il veut
rééquilibrer le pouvoir
alors peut-être on peut dire un mot sur
le futur où l'actuel produit moins on va
y venir d'abord déjà su remettre vdf
déjà pourquoi cette décision alors on
sait que dmitri medvedev était aux
environs de 30 % dans les sondages
l'avaient perdu en popularité ces
derniers temps c'est l'une des des
principales raisons je crois que les
noms sont bons en dehors il a il a perdu
en notoriété
je croit l'analyse que je fais par
rapport aux successeurs
il n'a pas été assez effectifs j'irai
pas c'est pas un homme assez fort qui a
su imposer des décisions difficiles
s'est entendu avec menace et que c'est
un peu ce que l'on peut lire que poutine
a dit écoutez il suffit pas de parler
suis pas de faire d'éclat il faut il
faut être proche des gens il faut les
satisfaire il a montré en avait parlé en
décembre
bon il ya d'immenses succès sur l'appui
extérieur mais il ya des inégalités il
ya des pauvretés il ya le problème
démographique est vraiment pratiquement
dramatique 1 donc il faut quelqu'un qui
puisse qui est effectif et peut-être que
medvedev là dessus il s'est relâché avec
l'âge il a trop gros c'est un pays
extrêmement compliqué il a perdu un
petit peu 7,7 maestra cette capacité
d'imposer des décisions parfois
impopulaires comme l'âge de la retraite
comme le système de santé comme
l'éducation et ainsi de suite donc il a
voulu amener du sang neuf en quelque
sorte et le sang neuf donc on y vient ce
nouveau premier ministre là encore une
surprise ou une surprise parce que il
est peu connu bon parions que j'écoutais
rang venant ici des commentaires
certains disaient ils auraient pu nommer
coudry d'alexis koudrine qui est un
vieil ami de poutine qui a été
d'ailleurs classé par le financial times
le meilleur ministre des finances du
monde
et là et donc il aurait été un bon
candidat mais il a un certain âge là il
met du sang neuf
alors qui est monsieur michou chine pas
facile à preuve c'est qu'il a volée cela
hier matin que vous allez faire quoi
mme islami et bien alors il est
impressionnant on gagne là il a un
cerveau il ay la ja non mon voyais là
une force intellectuelle
certains le qualifient j'ai entendu
c'est moi qu'il dit le technocrate le
plus efficace de la russie et le
financial times un corps il a institué
on sait que les impôts dans tous les
pays du monde évidemment c'est monsieur
qui resterait il est à la tête du
système fédéral des impôts 2008 2010 et
il resterait au dire du financial times
qui est très critique vis-à-vis de la
russie généralement le système fiscal
des rameaux un des plus efficaces du
monde
chapeau parce que c'était pas facile de
collecter les impôts en russie et je
rappelle que le taux d'imposition
pour nous c'est un paradis c'est 13%
pour le monde
bon entre et donc c'est quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un qui est à la fois acceptable
pour le clan des siloviki que les
structures de force
c'est à dire le le fsb l'armée les
milices laumes
voilà et en même temps pour les libéraux
c'est à dire les économistes parce qu'il
a un profil qui est acceptable pour les
deux îles et il a il est docteur en
sciences économiques alors que médaille
était juriste il a commencé sa carrière
dans les ordinateurs dans les systèmes
complexes
il a travaillé dans le privé d'ailleurs
une société quitté relation avec la
deutsche bank
donc vraiment il a un curé qui l'homme
très complexe et donc c'est un homme
efficace qui va qui va justement
et si vous l'a dit mir poutine l'a nommé
c'est pour passer à une autre phase
justement ça sera ma dernière question
ce qu'elle est sans fil à quoi doit-on
s'attendre comme changement avec cet
homme eh bien je crois qu'il va mettre
l'accent sur le relèvement d'économie la
démographie le système social
l'éducation tous les problèmes pour ans
pour répondre aux besoins de la société
russe qui a quand même souffert de la
crise dont le taux d'expansion
économique est faible encore trop faible
et donc il faut que la machine sociale
économique et de plus de rendement et
donc il a donné les mains de cette
machine si vous passez l'émanation un
vrai technicien qui va accélérer la
marche vers plus de croissance plus
d'égalité plus d'efficacité dans tous
les domaines éducation santé
infrastructures et qui devra composer
également avec les sanctions économiques
internationales ça on verra on verra
pour l'instant ils ont été reconduits on
attend vous savez on verra si
l'évolution est bien en ukraine il ya eu
un échange de prisonniers que vous avez
840 le plus grand depuis le début de la
crise la guerre et donc si vraiment ça
évolue ce que celle veut ils pourront
être levés mais voyez l'europe c'est
quand même un mammouth qui est tellement
lent pour le mou voire faut vraiment le
pousser tous les côtés comme peut-être
qu'il faut espérer
merci beaucoup aux jeunes berg d'avoir
été avec nous et ancien ambassadeur de
france également essayiste merci merci
nous analysons les jours au gouvernement
et cette surprise aujourd'hui que les
démissions de une bonne je prie le
gouvernement russe merci à vous bonsoir
la colère ne retombe pas en iran après
le crash la semaine dernière de l'avion
ukrainien pour le quatrième jour
consécutif les iraniens
donc très indignés sont descendus dans
la rue hier pour rappel 176 personnes
dont de nombreux étudiants ont été tuées
dans l'avion avait tué par erreur
téhéran a annoncé avoir procédé à
plusieurs arrestations et ce matin le
président oignies appelé à l'unité
nationale il a également réagi à la
procédure lancée la veille par les
européens pour contraindre téhéran à
respecter l'accord sur le nucléaire les
explications de cyrielle benavides
bulbul ans
le ton monte entre téhéran et le rock ce
matin à san juan il ne mâche pas ces
mois les soldats européens déployés au
moyen-orient pourrait être en danger
après que la grande bretagne la france
et l'allemagne et défier terran pour
avoir brisé les limites de son accord
nucléaire de 2015 aujourd'hui le soldat
américain est en danger demain le soldat
européens pourraient être en danger
des déclarations qui font suite à la
décision hier de trois pays co
signataire de l'accord de vienne qui ont
lancé le mécanisme de règlement des
différends une procédure pour
contraindre la république islamique à
respecter ses engagements nucléaires au
risque d'un rétablissement des sanctions
de la part de l'onu nous n'avons plus
d'autre choix
étant donné les mesures prises par
l'iran que de faire part aujourd'hui de
nos préoccupations quant au fait que
l'iran ne respecte pas ses engagements
au titre du gie cypihot et et de saisir
la commission conjointe dans le cadre du
mécanisme de règlement des différends
conformément aux dispositions du
paragraphe 36 ipo et ce faisant nos
trois pays ne rejoignent pas la campagne
visant à exercer une pression maximale
contre l'iran nous agissons en toute
bonne foi avec l'objectif primordial de
préserver l'accord et dans l'espoir
sincère de trouver une solution pour
sortir de l'impasse
par le biais d'un dialogue diplomatique
constructif tout en restant dans son
cadre nous espérons ramener l'iran au
plein respect des engagements au titre
du gie cipi way ce dispositif est
soutenu par les états unis
pour autant l'europe ne souhaite pas
accentuer les sanctions contre téhéran
et entend sauver l'accord sur le
nucléaire et pour en parler nous sommes
avec nasser et hemani journaliste
spécialiste de l'iran merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
quelque chose d'assez notables
aujourd'hui le président iranien dont
croit ni
à qui a appelé à un changement dans le
mode de gouvernance de son pays
on sait évidemment on l'a rappelé qu'il
ya beaucoup de manifestations après ce
crash de l'avion abattu par erreur
ça veut dire quoi comment vous
l'interprétez on doit lire un début de
remise en cause et deux changements
peut-être si vous permettez je fais
juste une petite remarque j'ai lu ce
matin c'est ses propos certes il a parlé
de la nécessité de respecter le
pluralisme
surtout à l'approché des législatives
qui va intervenir d'ici peu mais cela
fait partir du jargon de teulel dite
modérée de régime iranien
mais depuis plus de deux décennies mais
cela reste également sans effet mais il
a surtout parlé de la nécessité de
changer les règlements militaires et
cela dans le contexte actuel le crash de
l'avion ou craignent un abbatu par la
défense et rien des gardiens de la
révolution pour que à l'avenir dit il
cela ne puisse pas se répéter donc les
mécontents du pouvoir iranien
voilà pour en être que déçu il s'agit
voilà deux changements cosmétiques d'un
point de vue militaire mots nous dit
mais en aucun cas un changement dans la
gouvernance politique c'est ce qu'on
trempe en fait le régime iranien vient
de confronter peut-être à une crise
politique majeure sans précédent ce qui
l'a déclenchée c'est tout coût important
après la mort l'élimination de russell
slimani l'eau militaire le plus
important du régime mais également ce
crash de l'avion civil l'ukrainien ou
176 passagers ont perdu leur vie cela a
créé des émotions l'important à travers
tout pays
les gens sont descendus dans la rue les
gens qui sont déjà en fait
désillusionnés désabusé pour crier leur
désespoir et leur absence de toute
confiance dans un système qui a qui
traverse une crise de légitimité ou
plutôt dit légitimité politique aggravée
par le contexte actuel alors c'est vrai
qu'on a vu à la mort du général
soleimani a battu
par les états unis a tué par les états
unis un moment plutôt d'unité nationale
en iran ça veut dire que c'était une
toute petite partie finalement de la
population ou alors une partie d'entre
eux se sont aussi retournés après cette
erreur concernant l'avion comment je
pense que j'ai eu l'occasion justement
d'apporter ce sujet d'ici quelques jours
quand cela est arrivé avec vous sur ce
plateau
j'ai dit que je dis que finalement ce
sont des moments à sage et le régime
iranien confrontés à des crises
important espérer pourvoir unir sa base
il a mis en mots qu'un des moyens
logistiques assez important pour montrer
qu'on disait le porte parole du
gouvernement iranien
1 et spectacles unité nationale mais
comme nous avons dit non mais alors
c'est vrai il y avait certainement des
gens convoqué sans doute pas on le sait
mais il est beaucoup de monde quand même
il y avait là il y avait entre 200 et
250 mille personnes que je les dis oui
il faut le capital iranien contenu de 14
voire 15 millions d'habitants vous voyez
le régime iranien essaye de montrer sa
légitimité à travers ce type de
manifestation mais vous savez que dans
le monde moderne pour approuver sa
légitimité
voilà on se réfère plutôt aux urnes on
organise des élections libres et pons
savoir si il y avait là une légitimité à
ce justement il ya des prochaines
élections légistatives vous l'avez dit
le 21 février est ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à une première étape dans le
changement ce qu'on prend le tournant le
vent de ce changement en iran
vous savez c'est assez tôt de le dire
mais tout indique pour le moment il y à
d'intenses de corée elle au sein de
systèmes entre deux ailes moi j'ai lu ce
matin comme je disais il ya un instant
les propos de hassen voran y joue
permettez moi ce pronostic cette
impression qui laissait entendre qu'en
fait que le crash de l'avion et
ukrainiens s'étaient bien vous nous
intentionnel et cela devait était là
prêt nous des coûts forcé par les
gardiens de la révolution
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela en fait qu'il
a demandé expressément aux gardiens de
la révolution d'expliquer en détails aux
iraniens comment une chose paraît que
lui-même trouvé incroyable à plus arrivé
on va voir dans les jours à venir
d'ailleurs la prière de vendredi doit
être dirigée par le guide suprême
chose qu'il ne fait que dans le moment
de crise politique assez important je
pense que le régime iranien est
confronté à des crises important est que
poté d'ici les législatives beaucoup de
choses pour arriver
pour le moment ce qui a pu gagner c'est
avant tout le président américain merci
donald trump en tout cas 9 r et m a dit
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
pour avoir apporté votre analyse
dans quelques instants nous recevons
notre invité politique juliette mais
elle est l'ancienne secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'aide aux victimes ancien
porte parole du ps candidate sans
étiquette désormais aux municipales à
montrouge et puis nous irons également
au québec où les conséquences de
l'éventuelle installation du duc et de
la duchesse de sussex fait déjà
polémique
[Musique]
le lac 6 anti fait partie d'une réserve
naturelle à haute altitude
[Musique]
c'est là que le célèbre fleuve le site
arômes commence son voyage
c'est la principale voie navigable
d'indonésie
le site a room est désormais une fosse
septique géante
le fleuve s'étend sur 300 kilomètres de
sa source à son embouchure et compte
plus de 2000 installations industrielles
réparties le long de ses rives
l'eau est devenue noire parce que les
déchets liquides de lusine ne sont pas
filtrées
lors du site arômes iric plus de 4000
rizières et fournit de l'eau potable à
25 millions de personnes
nous n'avons qu'un fleuve et c'est le
fleuve le plus polluées du monde
[Musique]
les ogm c'est la cerise sur le gâteau de
la culture intensive et chimiques ou le
nombre de techniques pour faire des ogm
a explosé pendant les 15 dernières
années les ogm c'est un outil c'est tout
ce qu'il a il ne pourra rien faire
contre la faim dans le monde
puisqu'en fait la faim dans le monde est
une question politique alors ça c'est
les ogm
il ya également le glyphosate alors le
livre 7 à usage agricole on pourrait
s'en passer il ya des façons de produire
qui peut se passer de tout herbicides il
ya des gens qui ont un intérêt à ce que
ces molécules hla soient pulvérisés sur
les champs ce que ça rapporte énormément
d'argent
peut-être que ça arrange industrie qu'on
parle que du glyphosate parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres herbicides
ils sont en jeu et le glyphosate et
d'une molécule qui est tombé dans le
domaine public
elle n'a plus de problème dans tout le
monde peut en produire il ya d'autres
termes sites qui sont en train d'arriver
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont de
l'ordre de l'économie d'accord on nous
impose ces choses là
non pas parce qu'il ya un intérêt social
parce qu'un intérêt économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
20h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france au 42e journée consécutive de
grève contre la réforme des retraites
demain nouvelle grande journée d'action
interprofessionnelle prévue pour
continuer de réclamer le retrait du
projet et puis on l'apprend ce soir
l'intersyndicale qui annonce une
nouvelle grande journée de grèves et de
manifestations ce sera le 24 janvier
prochain écoutez le premier ministre à
l'occasion d'un séminaire gouvernemental
aujourd'hui la grève à la ratp la grève
à la sncf me paraissait sans issue et
qu'elle n'avait que trop duré depuis des
cendres nous sommes restés constants et
fermes sur la suppression des régimes
spéciaux
nous avons veillé à trouver et à
proposer des transitions longue dans les
entreprises publiques de transport
conformément à ce à quoi nous nous
étions engagés très tôt dans le
processus de réflexion sur la mise en
place de ce système universel de
retraite les propositions que nous avons
formulées permettent de dessiner le
respect des parcours individuels et des
attentes légitimes mais nous avons fait
ces propositions et je pense qu'il est
temps de sortir par le haut après les
organisations syndicales de la fonction
publique se sont elles aussi rassemblées
à midi devant le ministère des finances
à paris à l'appel notamment de la cgt fo
fsu et sud notre reporter ni la fameuse
ou étaient sur place ils étaient entre
150 et 200 personnes rassemblées ici
devant bercy parmi les manifestants
principalement des salariés de la
fonction publique des enseignants des
agents de la ratp ou encore du personnel
de santé qui étaient là pendant deux
heures pour discuter des prochaines
actions à mener pour poursuivre ce bras
de fer qui est engagé depuis
quarante-deux jours maintenant
avec le gouvernement je proposais les
écouter il était important pour nous de
montrer la détermination des
fonctionnaires et nous sommes là dans un
rassemblement militant devant bercy
parce que bercy
il était important qu'on soit là c'est
là où se négocie et leur maman de
dossiers dont celui de la catégorie
active pour les hospitaliers que je
représente aujourd'hui parce que je suis
là au titre de la fédération des
services publics et de santé force
ouvrière pour les hospitaliers et les
territoriaux de france et donc il était
important qu'on soit là pour montrer
notre détermination à continuer le
mouvement malgré les de cette
mobilisation qui dure depuis quarante
deux jours maintenant les annonces du
premier ministre concernent que la shdm
niveau qui est un des éléments de cette
réforme
ce qu'il ya de malheureux c'est que il
faudrait que tous les salariés de france
soit dans la rue parce qu'on va tous
prendre plein la tête qu'on reçoit du
privé ou du public
il suffit simplement c'est mathématique
un calcul des pensions de retraite qui
est sûre calculé sur l'ensemble de la
carrière et non pas sur les meilleurs
mois de salaire forcément c'est
mathématique
le montant de la retraite ou de la
pension pour la fonction publique sera
inférieur à ce qu'il est actuellement et
malgré la volonté du gouvernement de
trouver une issue à cette crise les
manifestants restent déterminés ils
demandent le retrait pur et simple de la
réforme des retraites
cris pour décrypter l'actualité nous
sommes avec juliette mais adel ancien
secrétaire d'état chargé de l'aide aux
victimes ancien porte parole du ps
candidate désormais sans étiquette aux
municipales à montrouge c'est notre
invité politique ce soir
bonsoir juliette mais adel merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
vient de l'entente d'edouard philippe
qui restent déterminés tout le monde
doit s'en sortir par le haut selon lui
qui estime que la grève n'a que trop
duré et qu'elle est sans issue qu'en
pensez vous
d'abord c'est vrai que c'est difficile
pour tout le monde en ce moment parce
que la grève ça perturbe le
fonctionnement général des transports
etc mais il faut quand même dire que le
sujet de taille et on comprend aussi
l'inquiétude l'inquiétude que nous avons
sur l'avenir des retraites de nos
enfants et puis sur ce sentiment plus
que le projet du gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'est pas complètement
stabilisé sur le financement notamment
car si l'âge pivot aujourd'hui est
provisoirement retiré du projet de loi
comment et de quel façon va-t-on
financer cet énorme besoin de
compensations en matière de retraite et
puis surtout sur la justice c'est aussi
ce qui justifie les graves
comment garantir que chacun sera traitée
équitablement et dans la justice
et vous ne faites pas confiance au
gouvernement quand il martèle c'est une
mesure de justice sociale justement
chaque point cotisé chaque fois récupéré
la même chose pour tous notamment pour
les mères de famille bref vous n'avez
pas confiance
c'est pas que je n'ai pas confiance
c'est que il faut des preuves
vous savez c'est comme en amour il faut
des preuves d'amour et donc ça fait deux
ans et demi qu effectivement ce projet
de réforme sur des principes qui sont
auquel on adhère tous si l'idée demain
et d'avoir un régime de retraite
universel équitable et juste
on est tous d'accord avec ça seulement
ça fait deux ans et demi que des
discussions étaient engagées et qu'on ne
comprend toujours pas comment ce texte
va aboutir
et là cette incertitude créé de
l'angoissent et l'angoissent crée de la
défiance
d'où les grèves qui effectivement sont
pénibles pour tout un chacun pour les
grévistes aussi car c'est un manque à
gagner pour les commerçants
je vois à montrouge dans ma ville
effectivement les commerçants centre
mais aussi pour se déplacer c'est à dire
que les grèves créé des embouteillages à
montrouge
il y en avait déjà beaucoup ont depuis
trois ans il y en a encore plus
donc maintenant il est temps que tout ça
s'arrête mais autour d'un projet qui
soit un projet juste et partagée
la cfdt
a dit qu'elle se satisfaisait du retrait
de l'âge pivot non il faut que l'on
comprenne que tous les français
comprennent où le gouvernement va
commencer finances et de quelle manière
le système des retraites permettra à
chacun d'avoir une retraite convenable
vous faites partie des gens qui estiment
qu'on n'a pas forcément besoin de cette
réforme on vous avait dit oui à une
réforme juste parfaite ok tout le monde
est paumé est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
de cette réforme
certains pensent que non moi je crois
que si parce qu'on connaît la pyramide
des âges et on sait très bien qu'il ya
un moment où il faudra travailler plus
longtemps mais si vous voulez le
professeur de fac il peut travailler
plus longtemps il peut même travailler
jusqu'à 70 ans l'avocat aussi en
revanche l'employé ou l'ouvrier ou celle
où la caissière dans un supermarché qui
subit une forte pression et toutes ces
personnes qui sont soumises à une
pression au travail à la souffrance au
travail
toutes ces personnes là doivent pouvoir
partir plus tôt donc la justice et ça
c'est de reconnaître la pénibilité et
c'est de permettre à chacun d'avoir une
retraite aussi décente que possible et
qui permettent aussi à chacun de pouvoir
profiter de l'espérance de vie qui ne
cesse de s'allonger
chaque année on l'a dit vous et qui
porte parole du parti socialiste
désormais sans étiquette on expliquera
peut-être un peu plus tard pourquoi vos
ex collègues ont publié leurs propres
projets ils refusent tout financement
qui reposerait sur un nouvel allongement
de la durée de cotisation ils veulent
pas d'âge qui volent et réclament le
maintien du départ à 60 ans pour les
carrières longues plaines da pour une
règle d'or qui permet de garantir les
pensions plus de ponction à sur les
hauts revenus 1 jusqu'à 27 mille euros
notamment 28,1 pour 100g pas rentrer
dans des détails trop techniques de
cotisation contribution des revenus
financiers vous en pensez quoi vous êtes
en accord avec vous vous avez d'autres
plans peut-être je pense qu'il faut être
cohérent
c'est à dire que moi j'ai fait partie
d'un gouvernement qui précisément à
allonger la durée de cotisation est
pourquoi pour des raisons aussi de
réalisme
donc il faut être cohérent et dire
reconnaître qu'on est aujourd'hui plus
de 65 millions que la pyramide des âges
est inversée convient
de plus en plus longtemps et donc il est
légitime et normal de chercher à faire
en sorte que le système des retraites
soient financées et soit équilibré
maintenant ce qui est indispensable
c'est qu'on arrive à mettre en place
mais une prise en compte de la
pénibilité qui soit simple à mettre en
oeuvre d'un gouvernement auquel j'ai
appartenu nous avions pris en compte la
pénibilité mais c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué c'est dans la mise en place
donc ce qu'il faut ce à quoi il faut
travailler c'est ça c'est à dire qu'il
faut que ce soit facile de reconnaître à
chacun en fonction de la difficulté de
ces conditions de travail
ces conditions de retraite en tireront
pleinement compte et je pense en
particulier à la situation des femmes à
la situation des femmes seules à celles
qui ont un ou plusieurs enfants leur
poulain conditions doit être prise en
charge alors je suis pas totalement
alignée sur ce que propose le parti
socialiste je trouve qu'il ya un certain
nombre de dogmes la question de l'âge
pivot qui est un qui est devenu un totem
dans le débat actuel devrait être
considéré avec beaucoup plus de
souplesse ce qu'ils vont prendre en
compte c'est la durée totale de
cotisations
donc quand on a commencé à travailler
tôt on doit pouvoir s'arrêter au terme
de la même durée de travail que quand on
a commencé à travailler tard et ensuite
chacun doit pouvoir bénéficier d'un
ajustement en fonction de la difficulté
objectivables de ses conditions de
travail
emmanuel macron a dit aujourd'hui qu'il
s'exprimer prochainement sur les
retraites dans les prochaines semaines
vous attendez quoi qu'est ce que vous en
attendez en tout cas du président moi
j'attends du président de la clarté
c'est à dire qu'on a besoin de savoir
quel est son cap où il va et comment il
y va la clarté sur la justice sociale
et puis surtout de la clarté dans la
mise en oeuvre des règlements considérer
aujourd'hui que le système est universel
mais qui a toute une série d'exceptions
c'est déjà reconnaître que la retraite
par points a du plomb dans l aile
donc il faut clarifier et il faut
surtout rassuré les générations futures
vous êtes candidate à montrouge on en
parlera sans étiquette vous aviez appelé
à voter justement emmanuel macron dès le
premier tour des élections
présidentielles de 2017 vous avez été
radié pour cela
du parti socialiste vous avez des
regrets aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
toujours macron compatibles quel est
votre vue sur ce premier bilan qui est
déjà d'ailleurs bien entamé des manuels
mettront alors d'abord je n'ai pas de
regret parce que quand j'ai appelé à
voter macron dès le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle une santé il
me semblait que c'était mon devoir
car la social-démocratie n'avait plus de
candidat manuel valls avait été éliminé
et le parti socialiste dans sa son
histoire classique qui est l'histoire
d'un parti qui était devenu social
démocrate n'avait plus de candidats donc
je ne regrette pas ce choix
je suis néanmoins dubitative est pour le
moins un peu critique sur deux aspects à
mi mandat
le premier aspect c'est la question
écologique on trouve que on peut pas
considérer aujourd'hui que ses deux
premières années et était innovante et
audacieuse en matière écologique
j'aurais voulu qu'on aille beaucoup plus
loin sur le sur l'interdiction du
glyphosate sur l'alimentation pour on
pourrait faire bien plus d'efforts il ya
des l'écologie aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
une idéologie c'est toute une série de
réformes qu'on peut mettre en place en
discutant mondiale aux gants sans
forcément il y avait les meilleures
années mais nicolas hulot alors il a mis
en cause les lobbys est-ce qu'on est
gangréné justement sur cette question de
l'écologie par les lobbys en france
écoutez moi je vais travailler avec
nicolas hulot qui juste venu à montrouge
on a travaillé ensemble sur la
révolution écologique bien sûr que les
lobbys ont un pouvoir qui aujourd'hui
est inacceptable en france alors les
lobbys pour ne pas les citer prenons
l'exemple de l'industrie agro
alimentaire
nous avons travaillé sur la loi pour
interdire l'usagé du plastique dans le
transport des aliments dans les écoles
et bien ce texte que que j'ai aidé à
porter dans lequel nous avons apporté
des amendements avec une association
impliquée à montrouge et qui aujourd'hui
soutient ma démarche municipale ce texte
là qui prévoyait l'interdiction du
plastique à échéance rapprochée
oui finalement a été reportée aux
calendes grecques
et il faudra attendre 2024 pour
interdire que l'on transporte les
aliments qui servent dans les cantines
pour les enfants pour interdire le
recours aux plastiques voiliers et sur
cet exemple là je sais gelé
j'ai vu l'immobile intervenir donc quand
un lobby intervient il faut au moins que
ce soit mis sur la place publique et il
faut que le politique impose l'intérêt
général et nicolas hulot raconte très
bien qu' il ya eu un manque de volonté
politique
c'est ce que je critique aujourd'hui
dans ses deux premières années sur la
question écologique
on aurait pu faire bien plus sans être
dogmatique
sans être dans l'écologie punitive on
pourrait très bien amener les
entreprises à s'engager dans une
transition mais à rythme accéléré
et c'est d'ailleurs l'intérêt de la
france l'intérêt de l'europe que
d'arriver à être innovant sur ce marché
de la transition écologique à propos
d'écologie
la transition est toute trouvée vers une
des actualités du jour ségolène royal
n'a pas dû passer une bonne journée un
edouard philippe qui dit cette dernière
la diplomatie c'est une mission la
politique c'en est une autre
elle est remerciée est ce qu'il y avait
un mélange des genres ségolène royal qui
est d'ailleurs visé par la même occasion
par une enquête préliminaire du parquet
national financiers pour concernant les
usages qu'elle fait des moyens à sa
disposition en tant qu'ambassadrice des
pôles votre vue là-dessus vous la
connaissez bien ségolène royal ont
d'abord il ya une enquête qui est
ouverte par le parquet une enquête
préliminaire du calendrier
donc je sais pas si c'est un hasard on
va laisser le parquet voilà lancé son
enquête
nous verrons peut-être que ça n'aboutira
pas nous verrons bien je vais pas me
prononcer là dessus maintenant ségolène
royal est une femme politique c'est elle
a été candidate à l'élection
présidentielle de 2007 les accompagner à
ce moment là c'est une femme courageuse
engagée qui se bat pour l'écologie qui a
des fortes convictions
donc elle a encore des tas de choses à
dire à la france elle a des combats à
mener
donc laissons la procédure arrivé à son
terme vous ne le criez pas bien vous
avez gardé toute votre oeil ségolène
volume ans je trouve que il ya peu de
femmes dans la vie politique française
hier peu de femmes qui ont fait la
démonstration de leur courage comme elle
c'est la seule qui sont arrivés au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
à part
le pen naturellement mais deux issus de
la gauche de gouvernement c'est la seule
et elle a toujours défendu une vision de
l'écologie audacieuse donc il y a les
vicissitudes de la vie politique
aujourd'hui je crois qu'elle a encore
des choses à dire dernière question elle
concerne les municipales dans le disait
vous êtes candidate à montrouge
désormais sans étiquette vous n'avez pu
le soutien de la majorité présidentielle
vous le regrettez ça va être d'autant
plus difficile ou au contraire peut-être
que c'est pas si mal que ça finalement
aujourd'hui je suis très heureuse je
suis une candidate libre et je crois
pour des élections municipales
il faut vraiment se concentrer sur ce
qui intéresse les morgiens il n'y a pas
de nationalisation du scrutin comme j'ai
pu l'entendre ici ou là après tarbes y
intéressions seul environ je crois que
ce qui intéresse aujourd'hui les
électeurs et en particulier mon rouge
c'est la capacité des candidats répondre
à leurs attentes
alors on peut essayer de faire du gauche
droite on veut essayer de calquer et
d'essayer d'en faire un scrutin national
je pense que c'est une erreur
je crois vraiment dans une ville comme
montrouge qui est une ville de près de
50 mille habitants c'est une ville qui a
de grosses attentes en matière de vie
quotidienne qui a été sacrifié depuis
trois ans par une gestion municipale qui
l'a dégradée aujourd'hui il ya des
embouteillages la circulation n'est pas
sûr
on souffre quand même beaucoup
aujourd'hui de la pollution de l'air à
mourouj reste une commune est juste à
côté du périph donc le stationnement le
prix du stationnement a été augmentée de
façon exorbitante par la municipalité
sortante donc la vie s'est dégradé
depuis trois ans et est donc comme la
vie s'est dégradée j'ai engagé cette
démarche avec en plus à coeur de
préparer l'avenir et dans une commune de
cette nature qui est très dense
aucune décision n'est prise par exemple
pour se protéger de la canicule à
montrouge aujourd'hui on coupe les
arbres dans toutes les villes de france
on plante des arbres pour se protéger de
la chaleur à mon âge ou coupent les
arbres 120 platanes ont été coupées où
on engage des travaux cher à montrouge
ont détruit les finances de la commune
puisque les deux tiers des réserves de
la commune ont été utilisés en l'espace
de deux ans donc il ya un gros enjeu et
je crois vraiment que les élections
municipales sont un moyen de chaud
la vie très concrètement par des
décisions qui sont d'édition que doit
être partagée moi je fais une campagne
où discutent avec les associations et
les entreprises les collectifs citoyens
ont construit un projet c'est un projet
co construit et je crois que l'avenir de
l'engagement politique commence par là
mais repart l'échelon local et
municipales merci beaucoup juliette
ahmed aller à voir et vous avez une
interactivité france merci
emmanuel mais croit présenté ses voeux à
la presse cet après midi après avoir
boudé l'exercice l'année dernière
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
sortir un peu plus du silence en plein
mouvement social ont fait le point sur
ce discours avec notre reporter katia
technique lors de ses voeux emmanuel
macron a tenu à rassurer la profession
notamment sur son avenir économique en
évoquant un plan de filière et une
protection face aux géants du numérique
a assuré également sur le pluralisme des
médias
laliberté presse ou encore la liberté de
blasphémer et puis il a assuré qu'il
referait les liens avec les journalistes
envers les
vous savez il a tenu souvent des propos
très durs des mots incompréhensibles
selon le président de l'association de
la presse présidentielle qui a inauguré
les voeux il a posé une question série
de questions au président emmanuel
macron s'est alors livré à un exercice
assez déconcertant il ay lui dit
certaines questions
il a contourné les critiques pour
parfois répond de manière assez
lapidaire c'était le cas avec la
question posée sur les violences
policières sur les journalistes durant
les manifestations
il a plutôt évoqué la question du
maintien d'ordre de la violence de rue
du fait que des forces de l'ordre
avaient souvent protégés des
journalistes pour enfin répondre à la
question posée
je vous propose de l'écouter il ya eu
dans le cadre des il y a dans le cadre
des manifestations
en effet des violences dans lesquelles
les journalistes ont pu être prises à
partie et non pas parfois pas pu faire
le travail comme il se devait et vous en
avez rappelé les termes et je les
condamne avec la même clarté et de la
même manière qu'eux il importe de
rappeler l'indispensable travail dans
une démocratie que font les forces de
l'ordre
ils sont au service de l'ordre public et
du respect de la loi
il importe d'exiger le respect de toute
la déontologie et d'exemplarité et c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé aussi des
propositions précises au ministre de
l'intérieur sur ce sujet et je souhaite
aussi d'ailleurs que au delà du dialogue
qui a commencé avec votre profession
pour clarifier sécuriser le cadre
d'intervention dans les manifestations
celui ci puisse encore être amélioré
pour qu aucune dérive ne soit possible
et que tous les journalistes qui sont
dans le cadre d'un événement quel qu'il
soit soit protégé de la violence et
puissent faire leur travail comme ils
doivent le faire
emmanuel macron a également répondu à
une question sur la loi contre les faits
que nous qui inquiète les journalistes
selon lui la loi qui régit actuellement
la profession n'est pas assez robuste il
faut de nouveaux outils
mais il a conseillé de ne pas
s'inquiéter puisque
le juge contrôlera et veillera au bon
processus démocratique et le président
français s'est livré une leçon de
journalisme face au parterre d'invités
il a dit que ce n'était pas au
gouvernement de décider qui était
journaliste et qu'il n'était pas mais
bien à nous et il a exhorté à
pourchasser les faux journalistes les
journalistes citoyens les autoproclamés
vidéaste blogueurs selon lui ce sont eux
la véritable menace de la profession
alors que cette question ne lui était
pas posée je vous propose de l'écouter
je pense pas que ce soit au gouvernement
de dire qui est journaliste qui ne l'est
pas quel est le statut de l'information
et cetera je n'ai jamais pensé cela et
je ne crois pas que ce soit une voie
dans laquelle nous ayons collectivement
à nous engager
mais je suis convaincu d'une chose c'est
que la société du commentaire permanent
n'est pas la société de l'information
et c'est que la multiplication des
auteurs possibles de traces de simili
journalistique est une menace pour votre
profession et pour la démocratie
il faut un moment quelqu'un pour pouvoir
dire d'où vient cette trace quel est son
statut qu'il a authentifié dans quel
contexte l été et pouvoir la qualifier
c'est la base de votre travail
mais si quiconque émettant depuis son
téléphone portable peut se considérer
comme journaliste vous permet de vous
dire que dans la base déontologique la
vocation même l'existence même de votre
profession la capacité à tenir dans la
durée sera difficile manuel macron a
conclu ses voeux en assurant qu'il
allait accorder davantage d'entretiens
aux journalistes qui s'étaient plaints
d'avoir trop peu de contacts avec la
présidence et en même temps il a débuté
ses voeux par une pique envers la
profession en paraphrasant le général de
gaulle
millet qui lisait la presse chaque matin
pour apprendre ce qu'il pensait même si
c'était faux une bonne entrée en matière
pour 2020
après le brésil le mexique si le prince
harry et meghan markle ont décidé de
s'installer à temps partiel au canada
cette venue du couple n'est pas sans
mettre en ébullition le pays et suscité
de nombreuses questions notamment des
questions en termes de coûts et de
statut le chef du bloc québécois yves
françois blanchet est très clair une
installation bienvenue mais pas aux
frais des québécois le premier ministre
canadien confirme d'ailleurs qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à discuter sur
comment notamment va se passer et quel
coût cela implique m et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis montréal
avec louis aucoin stratèges en
communication et gestion de crise et
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir le vo quoi merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce soir
pourquoi ces craintes des autorités est
ce qu'il ya vraiment un risque
finalement que ce couple vivent aux
crochets des canadiens ben oui un bar y
aurait à des risques effectivement c'est
un couple royal vacances vous savez en
colombie-britannique donc qu'une
affection pour le canada même si megan
est originaire des états unis donc il ya
cette question là est la question se
pose de différentes façons c'est assez
intéressant de louanges
comment au québec par exemple monsieur
yves françois blanchet qui représente un
parti indépendantiste nous dit vous
savez on peut accueillir n'importe qui
dans la mesure où on n'aura pas à payer
donc ça c'est une chose au canada on dit
vous n'êtes pas les bienvenus parce que
vous représentez sa majesté et on a déjà
un système pour représenter sa majesté
ça s'appelle le gouverneur général donc
si on reçoit au canada un représentant
de la famille royale par définition ça
devrait cette personne là qu'il devient
le représentant de la reine
donc ça pose un problème constitutionnel
alors c'est pour 6,5 que simplement dit
on prend un appartement à montréal à
toronto à vancouver
et puis on s'installe soulève de vraies
questions et je pense que ça dépasse de
loin la question des quelques millions
de dollars qui seront nécessaires à
assurer leur sécurité
alors justement
non c'est parti parce que ce couple
normalement veut prendre son
indépendance donc mais n'a pas vocation
à représenter comme vous dites là la
famille royale qu'est ce qui se dit au
canada justement il y aurait un peu de
confusion sur ces deux statuts si j'ose
dire ah oui il ya beaucoup de choses qui
se disent à d'abord vous savez cette
histoire là donc c'est le jeune couple
qui tente de s'affranchir
c'est une première glisse-t-on à
laquelle on peut se référer il savait
comme personne comme personne du public
en général
encore une première chose la manière
dont ce couple là fonctionnent ensemble
le fait que ce soit des milléniaux donc
qui ont des privilèges mais capital qui
accepte pas nécessairement toutes les
responsabilités qui viennent avec ecce
terra ça fait référence à plusieurs
clichés qui sont qui sont dans l'avenir
est dans une public comme ça quand ils
sont très connus
il faut voir que au canada la monarchie
elle est omniprésente on sent on se rend
compte peut-être pas toujours qu'on peut
être pas quand on visite vous savez
comme sens comme touristes mais quand on
vit ici on nous parle des procureurs de
la couronne dans les procès criminels là
quand vous êtes dans un procès criminel
vous assistez à un procès de la reine
contre un de ses sujets donc c'est c'est
tout si c'est comme ça
il est entreprises signent des contrats
avec le gouvernement du canada mais on
signe un contrat avec sa majesté
les navires de la marine ce sont les
navire canadien de sa majesté donc c'est
partout en tout temps évidemment vous
parle même pas de la monnaie
donc ni la monarchie et les un peu
partout mais elles ne représentent pour
la même chose que vous soyez au québec
chez les francophones où que vous soyez
au canada ce sont deux mondes distincts
parce que mais oui parce qu'au canada la
monarchie c'est ce qui nous distingue le
plus je dirais des états unis donc il ya
d'autres il ya d'autres distinctions
sociales si vous voulez tout mais sur le
plan culturel
mais la différence c'est le système du
pays
donc qui distingue les canadiens anglais
des américains
alors qu'au québec cet été tout un autre
monde la distinction et les multiples et
la monarchie ne fait pas partie des ce
dont on a besoin pour se distinguer du
reste de l'amérique du nord
vous voyez on a un rapport identitaire
totalement différent
à la monarchie et en plus la monarchie
représente le conquérant du québec vous
savez de la nouvelle france donc il ya
une relation amour-haine avec cette
monarchie britannique
alors ce ne sont pas plutôt les
détracteurs justement la lumière de ce
que vous nous dites du pouvoir royal qui
sont aujourd'hui les les plus critiques
envers cette venue temps mais
certainement que les détracteurs de la
monarchie viennent de trouver là vous
savez une espèce de deux raisons
supplémentaires de mettre en doute
l'utilité de la monarchie est
effectivement sur le plan simplement
utilitariste font fonctionner la
monarchie se soyons honnêtes on en a pas
besoin
mais par contre sur le plan identitaire
sur le plan des symboles la monarchie
elle est au coeur du canada
donc ce qu'on dit ici une partie du
débat c'est de dire vous savez la
monarchie on les accepte
mais on accepte à l'étranger alors c'est
l'entente qu'on a avec la couronne
britannique et c'est l'entente qui doit
être préservé
mais il n'y a pas seulement les
antimonarchistes r quand même les
monarchistes aussi parce qu'ils
attendent avec un immense espoir
des membres de la famille royale chine
ou kippour userait pour les monarchistes
y en a pas beaucoup mais on a quand même
si ce serait comme une forme de
reconnaissance de l'importance de leur
pays au sein du commonwealth ou sein de
la famille royale
alors c'est pas une opinion qui est
partagé par la majorité mais il faut
dire que elle existe
merci louis aucoin en tout cas
certainement communication et gestion de
crise d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la démission du
gouvernement russe et la révision de la
constitution annoncée par le président
poutine qui se prépare à l'avenir et
puis en france cette mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites qui loin d'être
terminée
[Musique]
geoffroy et loïc deux frères aventuriers
ont décidé de suivre le cours du
troisième plus grand fleuve du monde
les yankees notre objectif est simple
aller à la rencontre d'un fleuve
mythique qui telle une artère irrigue le
pays le plus peuplé au monde
[Musique]
en cinq mois de sa source sur les hauts
plateaux tibétains à son embouchure à
shanghai ils ont parcouru plus de 7000
km à moto et en tricycle à la découverte
du lien qui unit l'homme à l'eau
[Musique]
nous filons à toute allure vers de
nouvelles rencontres et des paysages qui
sans aucun doute vont encore beaucoup
nous surprendre
[Musique]
en direct ce navire est très simple mais
c'est pas du tout le cas
réalité le vrai maître c'est l'ours
blanc est en 2d le brise glace
nous avons entrepris une mission unique
peut être la première de ce type dans
l'histoire de la marine russe
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
arte france pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
vladimir poutine désigne le patron du
fisc michail miss austin ou comme
nouveau premier ministre une nomination
après l annonce du gouvernement de miti
medvedev ait une demande de changement
émerger au sein de la société selon
président russe hommes nouvelle journée
interprofessionnelle de grèves et
manifestations ce jeudi et le 24 janvier
on l'a appris ce soir emmanuel macron
promet lui de continuer expliquer la
réforme des retraites
sixième semaine de mobilisation donc un
rassemblement de fonctionnaires a eu
lieu devant le ministère des finances à
paris manifestation également de la
police scientifique et des travailleurs
portuaires hors de question de ralentir
edouard philippe donne le ton à l'issue
d'un séminaire gouvernemental détaillant
le calendrier des chantiers des six
prochains mois
dans le même temps emmanuel macron
renouer avec les r6 de présentation des
voeux à la presse pour recréer du lien
avait été journaliste pour communiquer
ou pour rassurer avec peut-être en ligne
de mire la présidentielle de 2022 ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
la russie a donc connu une journée très
important pour sa politique intérieure
entre projet de réforme
constitutionnelle et démission de son
gouvernement
le mandat de vladimir poutine prend une
nouvelle direction retour sur les faits
avec robin pu l
la journée a commencé de façon très
solennelle vladimir poutine s'est
exprimé lors de son discours annuel
devant l'assemblée fédérale qui réunit
les deux chambres du parlement russe
durant cette allocution il a abordé la
situation économique ou encore la
question de la démographie en russie
mais vladimir poutine a également
proposé une série de réformes
constitutionnelles des propositions qui
seront soumises à un référendum et qui
répondent à la demande de changement qui
a émergé au sein de la société
l'adoption d'une nouvelle constitution
je crois que ce n'est pas nécessaire ces
potentiels de la constitution de 1993
est loin d'être épuisée et les
fondements du système constitutionnel
les droits et libertés de l'homme
j'espère resteront pour de nombreuses
décennies encore une passe de valeurs
solides pour la société russe la russie
est confrontée à des tâches historiques
et la contribution de chacun est
important
ensemble nous allons certainement
changer pour le set
j'utilise souvent ce mot ensemble parce
que la russie c'est nous des évolutions
qui devraient déterminer les grandes
lignes de la politique adoptée par
vladimir poutine
jusqu'à la fin de son mandat en 2024 des
réformes de la constitution qui devrait
permettre un rééquilibrage entre le
pouvoir présidentiel et celui du
parlement comme l'expliquent le sénateur
aleksei guskov et je pense qu'il est
venu à la conclusion que il faut
posséder une
ce que j'appellerais une démocratisation
du pouvoir présidentiel en russie
ça ne veut pas dire que le président on
va être destitué de ses pouvoirs et de
venir
une personne était honoraires comme dans
quelques pays acp
le président on va toujours conservé 2
prérogatives assez importante mais il
doit compter plus avec le parlement et
le gouvernement parce que d'après les
propositions de monsieur poutine
le parlement va décider qui sera le
premier ministre et qui seront et quelle
sera la formation du cabinet donc ça
sera un système mélangés dans la foulée
de ces annonces le premier ministre
dimitri medvedev a présenté la démission
de son gouvernement
une décision de la part de ce proche de
vladimir poutine qui a surpris mais dont
l'objectif est de faciliter la
réalisation des réformes voulues par le
président russe
ces changements lorsqu'ils seront
adoptées selon toute probabilité cela se
fera après une discussion comme cela a
été dit apporteront des modifications
importantes non seulement un certain
nombre d'articles de la constitution
mais aussi dans l' équilibre du pouvoir
dans son ensemble au sein du pouvoir
exécutif pouvoir législatif et pouvoir
judiciaire dans ce contexte il est
évident que nous en tant que
gouvernement de la fédération de russie
tu es l'une vont donner au président de
notre pays la possibilité de prendre
toutes les décisions nécessaires à cet
effet et dans ces conditions je pense
qu'il serait juste que conformément à
l'article 117 de la constitution de la
fédération de russie
le gouvernement de la fédération de
russie dans sa composition actuelle des
messieurs je remercie bien entendu ceux
qui ont participé au travail du
gouvernement il dans ses positions
et bien sûr les décisions suivantes
seront prises par le président du pays
une démission acceptée par vladimir
poutine qui a remercié le travail de son
ancien premier ministre pendant près de
8 ans le président a rapidement proposé
à michail michou steen d'occuper le
poste vacant
le patron du fisc russe inconnu du grand
public a accepté la proposition
sa nomination devrait être soumise au
parlement russe ce jeudi et pour en
parler nous sommes avec à claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison cette démission surprise
du gouvernement
pourquoi maintenant selon vous je crois
que
poutine avait annoncé lors de sa
conférence de presse annuelle il ya un
mois que il y avait des insuffisances
sur le plan économique et social et
qu'il y avait un certain mécontentement
dans la population
il en a tiré les conséquences et l'a dit
ce matin devant les deux chambres
réunies les corps constitués aussi
puisque on apercevait sur votre image
des noms députés notamment le le le
patriarche kirill qui était et bien
entendu au premier rang alors il a
évidemment fait des annonces majeures
dans cette intervention ce matin devant
les chambres réunies et notamment des
annonces de révision constitutionnelle
il ya très peu en russie il l'a dit
d'ailleurs la constitution c'est celle
de 93 donc elle et elle est essentielle
elle a été modifiée
peu de foi la principale c'est en 2008
par le président medvedev qui a allongé
le mandat présidentiel de quatre ans à 6
ans mais sinon c'est à peu près la même
constitution et donc il a annoncé un
certain nombre de choses alors pourquoi
s'il ya un mécontentement dans la
population
je crois que ce qui est apparue après la
réélection de la dîmière poutine au
printemps 2010 8
c'est qu' un certain nombre de mesures
économiques et sociales étaient mal
reçue par la population l'augmentation
deux points de la tva donc une réduction
est évidemment du pouvoir d'achat la
réforme des retraites et dans beaucoup
de pays c'est un sujet en effet qui
provoque des réactions
et puis le fait aussi que on avait
l'impression que peut-être il fallait un
petit peu changé les têtes du
gouvernement et par conséquent monsieur
medvedev en a tiré les conclusions et a
démissionné avec l'ensemble de son
gouvernement
et monsieur poutine va nommer un nouveau
il a proposé un premier ministre qui
doit être approuvé encore par là
confirmé par la douma
et puis il entamera la deuxième étape de
ce quatrième mandat
et c'est effectivement l'annoncent
peut-être
d'une sortie de piste en 2024 inverse a
en tout cas une révision de la
constitution en juillet c'est assez rare
en russie
en quoi ça va consulter alors l'une des
mesures principales ça va être de
rééquilibrer les pouvoirs entre le
président le premier ministre et le
parlement
à l'avenir c'est le parlement qui élira
le premier ministre et non plus qui
approuvera la nomination du président
donc c'est un changement et ça ressemble
davantage à un système parlementaire
classique européen
mais le président poutine a bien précisé
que le système rester fondamentalement
présidentielle
c'est à dire que c'est le président de
la république c'est le président de la
fédération de russie qui présidera le
conseil des ministres et qui prendra les
grandes décisions notamment les
nominations dans le domaine sécuritaire
donc ceci reste comme comme comme
auparavant mais donc un rééquilibrage
pour moderniser cette constitution
effectivement pour donner finalement
plus de pouvoir au parlement et plus de
responsabilités au gouvernement et son
premier ministre un parlement il faut le
dire qui est quand même majoritaire pour
l'instant majorité absolue dans l'est
dans les deux chambres
ce qui fait que la réforme
constitutionnelle or aucun mal à passer
il est dit consulterait la population
par ailleurs le référendum n'est pas
prévue dans la constitution actuelle
donc il faudra imaginer une forme de
consultation qui ne sera pas un vrai
référendum pour associer la population
parce qu'elle se soucie en effet d'aller
contre le sentiment de la population que
ces préoccupations ne sont pas prises en
compte et en effet le mécontentement
dans le domaine économique et social qui
se traduit aussi dans le domaine
démographique il a beaucoup parlé de
démographie mais là la faiblesse de la
démographie et les duos fait au dojo
faut que les gens estiment avoir peu de
perspectives aussi au fait que la durée
de vie
l'espérance de vie n'est pas très très
longue puisque pour un homme
actuellement en russie
ses 67 ans ce qui veut dire que les
services sociaux ne fonctionne pas bien
eugène die nous disait une manière pour
vladimir poutine d'aller vers davantage
de démocratie et peut-être entrer ainsi
dans l'histoire vous partager aussi
cette analyse de votre ex je crois mais
je crois qu'il faut se garder d' aller
trop vite tout est ouvert pour 2024
toutes les options sont ouvertes ce que
l'on sait et c'est en effet quelque
chose de majeur qui l'avait annoncé lors
de sa conférence de presse
c'est qu'il ne sera pas candidat
puisqu'il ne fait pas de modification de
la constitution permettant de faire un
troisième mandat consécutif
donc il ne sera pas candidat mais rien
n'était exclu après tout si on veut
faire de la politique fiction
on peut même imaginer ce qui n'est
probablement pas la meilleure solution
qu'ils se fassent désigné comme premier
ministre par le parlement
puisque c'est le parlement qui décidera
et qui dispose d'une majorité majorité
qui sera peut-être différente après les
élections qui auront lieu en 2021
d'ailleurs on a vu que les élections
locales dans les douma locale l'année
dernière ne se sont pas toujours très
bien passé à cause du mécontentement
populaire alors vladimir poutine on l'a
dit a désigné comme nouveau premier
ministre qui reste à valider vous l'avez
dit le patron du fisc russe mikhail
michaud steen inconnu du grand public
c'est difficile de se faire une idée sur
lui il fallait changer les têtes il
pouvait pas jouer avec des gens qui
avaient déjà eu des fonctions très
importante et qui ont toujours des
fonctions très importante soit dans le
gouvernement sont à l'administration du
kremlin qui est en fait un deuxième
gouvernement dans le système russe
par conséquent il a choisi en effet une
personnalité qui a fait une belle
carrière administrative puisqu'il est
chef du service fédéral des impôts
il est docteur en économie il avait fait
des études également à l'époque
soviétique dans le domaine des machines
outils il est donc ingénieur et il passe
pour être un très grand spécialiste du
numérique et c'est peut-être ça peut
être très utile pour faire entrer les
impôts et en effet ils passent pour
avoir tout à fait réussie
dans ce domaine avec un système fiscal
qui est assez favorable à l'épargné et
même certains disent aux riches puisque
comme vous le savez l'impôt sur le
revenu des personnes physiques n'est que
le 13 % taux unique pour tout le monde
est ce que ceux ci perdurera à l'avenir
en tout cas le nouveau premier ministre
est un très grand technicien de la
fiscalité est un bon économiste je crois
que la russie a besoin de bons
économistes
est ce qu'on peut imaginer d'autres
changements traits majeurs dans le
gouvernement pense notamment évidemment
en france à l'étranger à sergueï lavrov
est-ce qu'il va rester selon vous tout
le monde dit que sergueï lavrov est l'un
des meilleurs diplomates au monde donc
il est probable qu'il va rester mais les
affaires étrangères mais on peut aussi
lui confier une autre fonction il
pourrait faire ils pourraient montrer
tous ces talents et et prendre un autre
diplomate
au ministère des affaires étrangères je
crois qu'il est trop tôt pour le dire
chou qui est un poids lourd du
gouvernement ses ministres la défense
restera aussi reste sans doute
vraisemblablement sauf a encore une fois
surprise on verra on ne commentera avec
vaut certainement claude blanchemaison
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct avec
nous en france c'est la 42e journée
consécutive de grève et cette nouvelle
mobilisation aujourd'hui encore contre
la réforme des retraites à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale demain nouvelle grande
journée d'action interprofessionnelle
elle est prévue pour continuer de
réclamer le retrait du projet de système
de retraite universel à point à
l'occasion d'un séminaire gouvernemental
aujourd'hui le premier ministre est
revenu dans une allocution sur cette
réforme
la grève à la ratp la grève à la sncf me
paraissait sans issue et qu'elle n'avait
que trop duré depuis décembre nous
sommes restés constants et fermes sur la
suppression des régimes spéciaux nous
avons veillé à trouver et à proposer des
transitions longue dans les entreprises
publiques de transport conformément à ce
à quoi nous nous étions engagés très tôt
dans le processus de réflexion sur la
mise en place de ce système universal de
retraite les propositions que nous avons
formulées permettent de dessiner le
respect des parcours individuels et des
attentes légitimes mais nous avons fait
ces propositions et je pense qu'il est
temps de sortir par le haut la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites qui gagne les agents de la
police technique et scientifique en
grève depuis plusieurs jours aussi
manifesté dans la capitale le cortège
s'est élancé à la mi-journée du 7e
arrondissement parisien en plusieurs
services de police technique et
scientifique devaient également être
fermés sur ton territoire
notre reporter des qualifs a suivi ces
rassemblements entre 400 et 500
personnes selon les organisateurs
étaient un présent lors de cette
manifestation de la police scientifique
et technique
l objectif réclamer un statut d'actif
propre à la police nationale cette
distinction est vécue comme un manque de
reconnaissance par la profession qui
réclament depuis des années à un
alignement du statut d'actif qui ouvre
notamment un départ à la retraite
anticipée et pour ça il met en avant des
conditions de travail dangereuses et
pénible pour la plupart de des policiers
à présent aujourd'hui je vous propose
d'écouter georges ce n'est que membre du
syndicat snuipp ac
plus on avance dans le temps et plus la
police scientifique à des contraintes
particulière puisque je rappelle qu'on
est sur un statut des années 90 qui est
un statut des teknivals moratoire depuis
l'emploi a énormément changé
on met des contraintes de plus en plus
sur les collègues des astreintes de nuit
des délais des contraintes horaires des
contraintes de pénibilité de dangerosité
en intervention sur le terrain et
derrière ça suffit pas donc y en a un
peu ras le bol
on a des collègues on a un ça a explosé
avec le dossier retraites puisque on a
des collègues on se rend compte qu'ils
vont devoir travailler jusqu'à 65 67 ans
à faire de la constatation sur les
cadavres sur des scènes de crime
pour les retraites misérables de 1300 à
1400 euros par mois on a des collègues
là ici qui ont plus de 60 ans qui sont
avec nous aujourd'hui et c'est un
véritable tableau drame la manifestation
est partie sur les coups de midi trente
et plusieurs politiques étaient à
présent pour montrer leur soutien à ce
mouvement de protestation propose de les
écouter qu'ils ont des astreintes comme
c'est pas permis avec des jours de repos
qui sont extrêmement restant parfois
pire que leurs collègues d'actifs qui
est aussi son trait sont très sollicités
donc lors leur bataille elle est juste
elle est légitime
moi je suis très heureux très heureux
étaient ravis de les soutenir parce que
en plus au sein de la police nationale
la police technique et scientifique est
quand même monté en puissance mais pas
tant que ça donc proposé de doubler
leurs effectifs en l'élection
présidentielle et ils deviennent
aujourd'hui indispensable dans la
résolution des enquêtes
et puis bien sûr ça s'interroger sur les
statuts de ces personnels là qui ont
déjà été portées depuis 2015 il a failli
avoir un accord savoir pourquoi cet
accord et j'avoue que là je ne venais
pas dedans nous n'avons pas de
renseignements là dessus mais nous
allons nous y pencher savoir pourquoi
cet accord a échoué un mouvement de
contestation qui n'est pas près de
s'essouffler puisque la grève est
reconductible une situation inédite pour
la police scientifique et technique qui
est réclamé depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant ce statut d'actif
un chiffre à vous donner 30 % à des
affaires nationales sont résolus par la
police scientifique et technique elle
pour vous dire l'importance de ces de
cette section à l'intérieur même des la
police elle nationale c'est pour cela
qu'ils le réclament absolument ce statut
d'actif qui leur permettra de partir
notamment à la retraite
un peu plus tôt le port du havre bloquée
pendant au moins trois jours pour
réclamer le retrait du projet de réforme
des retraites et travailleurs portuaires
font grève depuis ce mardi ont fait le
point avec leila sarah fait pire que sa
vie hivernaux une nouvelle opération
portmore lancer une action à
l'initiative de la fédération nationale
cgt des ports et docks ce afin de
pénaliser l'activité
la semaine dernière déjà le port de
france avait été paralysé pendant trois
jours pour les mêmes revendications déjà
d'une sueur sur l'âge plus sur le départ
à la retraite à 64 ans la pénibilité on
a un métier où
ou on est déjà 8 ans en dessous de la
moyenne par rapport au décès sur les
ports français
donc oui c'est clair qu'il ya un impact
conséquent pour pour nous travailleurs
portuaires mais pas mais paul tuquoi via
les générations à venir et autres sont
impactés par cette dans cette réforme
une action qui n'est pas sans
conséquences pour l'économie locale
les grèves ont commencé début décembre
au moment où certains commerçants font
50 % de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
je pense que les mouvements sociaux ne
sont pas bons à court terme
si on regarde l'activité portuaire on a
des résultats directs avec des escales
annulé je suis aussi soucieuse pour les
commerces qui peuvent en pâtir je suis
aussi inquiète pour la suite pour le
moyen et à long terme 450 travailleurs
portuaires pour un mouvement inédit
depuis 1992
les militants se montre déterminé bien
sûr que l'on s'est mis d'accord les
instances de la fédération nationale
port et docks cgt se réunit
régulièrement sur paris pour décider des
actions à venir des actions qu'on veut
lieu précédemment donc
donc oui il ya un an payent et il est
clair on se doit d d'un combat pour se
faire retirer cette réforme qui est
néfaste pour les travailleurs portuaires
et france et français les manifestants
ne compte donc pas s'arrêter là
il prévoit également l'installation de
piquets de grève devant les directions
des grands ports maritimes ce vendredi
et pour en parler nous sommes avec hervé
des rédacteurs en chef de port et
corridors bonsoir et vds merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france donc
l'opération import mort aujourd'hui
lancé par les dockers cgt contre la
réforme des retraites on a peut-être
moins entendues alors vous peut-être non
parce que vous êtes dans cette presse
spécialisée mais on a peut-être moins
entendu s'exprimer les dockers sur la
question de cette réforme des retraites
qu'est ce que ça changerait pour ce
texte du gouvernement
écoutez d'abord juste pour remettre un
peu en perte et il est les éléments en
france il ya 19 ans c'est à dire on est
un élément il ya là 19 dont sept grands
ports maritimes les les dockers ont
connu une réforme en 2008 sur
l'organisation du travail pour s'aligner
sur les ports du nord
aujourd'hui ils sont face à un projet de
réforme des retraites alors
indépendamment de toute opinion sur ce
projet qui qui luttent contre lequel les
luttes ou depuis le 5 décembre il ya
beaucoup d'éléments qui ont fait que les
territoires sont bloqués aujourd'hui il
ya des effets sur toute la toute
l'industrie delà de la chaîne logistique
le projet en soi il est pas il concerne
pas que les dockers qui concerne tous
les travailleurs français donc le sujet
il n'est pas dockers reporter il est
national
avant toute chose c'est ce que rappelle
la fédération nationale des ports et
docks de la cgt alors justement
concrètement mon si on a compris vous
venez bien de nous l'expliquer que ça va
concerner tout le monde
qu'est ce que ça changera pour les
dockers ans
en particulier qu'elles sont là leur
litige et syfy cas alors le je pense que
et il faut remonter sur la réforme de
2008 quand ils ont une canton il la
réforme de 2008
ils ont négocié à l'intérieur de la
branche la pénibilité qui est elle une
pénibilité uniquement pour cette branche
de dockers qui prévoit un départ trois
ans avant la date normale hier que si
jamais vous deviez partir à 62 ans la
pénibilité telle qu'elle est prévue dans
la branche vous permet de partir à 50 9
en or avec ce projet de réforme
ce que dit la cgt la fnpd cgt
le pelage de l'âge de départ d'hercules
et est donc l'âge de départ de
pénibilité a reculé de la mecque
deleuze du même ordre deux groupes de
partis à à 59 ans comme vous pouviez le
prétend si vous aviez une activité
pénible
vous pourriez partir qu'à 61 ans ce qui
pour un joker qui et portiqueurs
c'est-à-dire question une brute à 40
mètres du sol ou qui est dans des
conditions parfois de très beaux chaleur
dans les ports quand il fait très chaud
l'été ou de grand froid quand en plein
hiver en plein air peut être un peu
difficile à vivre
justement est ce que ces deux car il
pense pouvoir tout de même obtenir
quelques concessions du gouvernement
selon vous je leur ai goûté
moi j'ai rencontré les responsables la
de l'année cnpd cgt j'ai rencontré des
responsables des organisations
patronales
ils restent tous un peu campé sur leurs
positions pour le moment on n'a pas
tellement de vision d'avenir on l'est
les trafic sncf très perturbée font que
les ports français souffrent énormément
ou aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya une
sortie une solution une sortie pour la
fnpd il ya lacunes c'est le retrait du
projet pour les industriels dans la cuve
c'est l'arrêt des mouvements et puis
peut-être des négociations mais
je pense que chacun essaye un peu de
camper sur ses positions et honnêtement
vu ma chaise d'observateurs les choses
ne vont pas en s'améliorant
alors je sais m'en vais de votre chaise
vous avez l'impression que les
situations va se radicaliser cette
opération port mort va durer jusqu'à
quand et surtout peut-être pour
intéresser les autres téléspectateurs
avec quelles conséquences en on est
mesure peut-être pas alors c'est vrai
que les médias se font assez peu le les
goûts de ses ports de ses mouvements
dans les ports on l'a vu là avec votre
journal
c'est intéressant mais alors le la fnpd
de voix se devait se réunir aujourd'hui
de ce qui nous avait dit et doivent
décider vendredi si le mouvement est
reconduit pour 72 heures de port nord la
semaine prochaine ou si il je cite
élèves la contestation à la quantité
élevée la contestation
ils ont été jusqu'à dire si le veau on
sera des mouvements de 96 heures par
semaine voire des mouvements illimités
donc ça signifie quoi ça signifie que
toute seule qui nous est importée en
france et c'est quand même un volume
assez important ne placera plus parlait
pas français à passer par des ports
étrangers
on peut passer par des ports étrangers
maintenant on risque d'avoir en effet
des problèmes de demandes de certains
produits
parce que ils mettront plus longtemps à
arriver dans le commerce que que
d'habitude donc c'est toute une
réorganisation
aujourd'hui beaucoup de commentateurs
vont dire anvers barcelone bilbao aux
gènes se frotte les mains de sa et
permettent aux ce modèle gagne des
trafics grâce à l'adresse panthères mais
bon les ports étrangers ont toujours été
meilleur que les parents ça jusqu'à
présente aujourd'hui c'est difficile de
savoir qu'on a encore tellement les
effets le premier effet c'était le brut
si demain nous
je n'arrive pas à rentrer dans les
raffineries on va très vite être en
rupture de stock sur sur l'essence si
demain on a pas on a un certain nombre
de produits de première nécessité qui
doit venir de l'étranger qui n'arrive
pas on risque d'arabes les produits d
des ruptures de stocks de certains
produits
c'est toute la chaîne logistique
internationale qui est mise à mal
voir qui va changer qui va être modifié
et qui risque d'être modifiées sur un
très long terme ce qui pour les ports
français et qu'elle va c'est dramatique
merci raymond puis on arrive à la fin de
l'interview merci je suis simplement
c'est que ces professionnels les
agressions patronale s'inquiète aussi
beaucoup d'avoir de savoir que edouard
philippe qui est un havre est d'origine
n'a pas su prendre la mesure de ce 2e
salle j'ai eu beaucoup de gens qui
viennent de toutes parts pour dire ça
merci beaucoup en tout cas hervé indice
de nous avoir fait voir plus clair un
petit peu sur ce conflit également fait
en tout cas cette vision du conflit des
retraites vu depuis des dockers merci à
vous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants notre débat sur la présentation
des voeux à la presse des manuels
maquereau dans le chef de l'état avait
boycotté l'exercice l'année dernière
autant il s'y est appliquée cette année
dans un contexte de mobilisation sociale
[Musique]
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés les contempler ces découvrir le
regard que portent les artistes sur leur
époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet
et cet enfant couvert de toute la
tendresse de sa mère peint par elisabeth
vigée lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peindre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
ensuite c'était l'enfer et ça reste un
enfer quand vous entrez la nuit c'est
effrayant
on sent ce sont les mêmes rails dans
lesquelles les juifs y compris ceux de
ma famille ont été transportés de
hollande à auschwitz birkenau
mon âme amsterdam rue rollix tracts ont
réparé la maison qui autrefois
appartenait aux parents de films encore
le plafond des toilettes a été démoli
une boîte contenant des lettres est
tombée sur le sol et la boîte avec les
lettres est tombée sur le sol j'ai
grandi sans savoir grand chose sur ma
famille les lettres de flip nous ont
permis d'en ressentir l'histoire et de
comprendre que j'en faisais partie
après j'ai découvert que non seulement
flip's filière a trouvé la mort ici avec
encore 118 autres membres de ma famille
ont partagé son destin
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre
emmanuel macron qui est donc présenté
ses voeux à la presse cet après midi
après avoir boudé on le rappelle
l'exercice l'année dernière l'occasion
pour les chefs des l'états de sortir un
petit peu plus du silence en plein
mouvement social
on fait le point sur le discours avec
notre reporter katia pique nique lors de
ses voeux emmanuel macron a tenu à
rassurer la profession notamment sur son
avenir économique en évoquant un plan de
filière et une protection face aux
géants du numérique a assuré également
sur le pluralisme des médias
la liberté de presse ou encore la
liberté de blasphémer et puis il a
assuré qu'il recevrait les liens avec
les journalistes envers lesquels vous
savez il a tenu souvent des propos très
durs des mots incompréhensibles selon le
président de l'association de la presse
présidentielle qui a inauguré les voeux
il a posé une question une série de
questions au président emmanuel macron
s'est alors livré à un exercice assez
déconcertant il a éludé certaines
questions
il a contourné les critiques pour
parfois répond de manière assez
lapidaire c'était le cas avec la
question posée sur les violences
policières sur les journal
durant les manifestations il a plutôt
évoqué la question du maintien de
l'ordre de la violence de rue du fait
que des forces de l'ordre avaient
souvent protégés des journalistes pour
enfin répondre à la question posée
je vous propose de l'écouter il ya eu
dans le cadre des il y a dans le cadre
des manifestations
en effet des violences dans lesquelles
les journalistes ont pu être prises à
partie et non pas parfois pas pu faire
le travail comme il se devait et vous en
avez rappelé les termes et je les
condamne avec la même clarté et de la
même manière qu'eux il importe de
rappeler l'indispensable travail dans
une démocratie que font les forces de
l'ordre
ils sont au service de l'ordre public et
du respect de la loi
il importe d'exiger le respect de toute
la déontologie et d'exemplarité et c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé aussi des
propositions précises au ministre de
l'intérieur sur ce sujet et je souhaite
aussi d'ailleurs que au delà du dialogue
qui a commencé avec votre profession
pour clarifier sécuriser le cadre
d'intervention dans les manifestations
celui ci puisse encore être amélioré
pour qu aucune dérive ne soit possible
et que tous les journalistes qui sont
dans le cadre d'un événement quel qu'il
soit soit protégé de la violence et
puissent faire leur travail comme ils
doivent le faire
emmanuel macron a également répondu à
une question sur la loi contre les faits
que nous qui inquiète les journalistes
selon lui la loi qui régit actuellement
la profession n'est pas assez robuste il
faut de nouveaux outils
mais il a conseillé de ne pas
s'inquiéter puisque le juge contrôlera
et veillera au bon un processus
démocratique et le président français
s'est livré une leçon de journalisme
face au parterre d'invités
il a dit que ce n'était pas au
gouvernement de décider qui était
journaliste
était pas mais bien à nous et il a
exhorté à pourchasser les faux
journalistes les journalistes citoyens
les autoproclamés vidéaste blogueurs
selon lui ce sont eux la véritable
menace de la profession alors que cette
question ne lui était pas posée je vous
propose de l'écouter je pense pas que ce
soit au gouvernement de dire qui est
journaliste qui ne l'est pas quel est le
statut de l'information et cetera je
n'ai jamais pensé cela et je ne crois
pas que ce soit une voie dans laquelle
nous ayons collectivement à nous engager
mais je suis convaincu d'une chose c'est
que la société du commentaire permanent
n'est pas la société de l'information
et c'est que la multiplication des
auteurs possibles de traces de simili
journalistique est une menace pour votre
profession et pour la démocratie
il faut un moment quelqu'un pour pouvoir
dire d'où vient cette trace quel est son
statut qu'il a authentifié dans quel
contexte l été et pouvoir la qualifier
c'est la base de votre travail
mais si quiconque émettant depuis son
téléphone portable peut se considérer
comme journaliste vous permet de vous
dire que dans la base déontologique la
vocation même l'existence même de votre
profession la capacité à tenir dans la
durée sera difficile manuel macron a
conclu ses voeux en assurant qu'il
allait accorder davantage d'entretiens
aux journalistes qui s'étaient plaints
d'avoir trop peu de contacts avec la
présidence et en même temps il a débuté
ses voeux par une pique envers la
profession en paraphrasant le général de
gaulle il a expliqué qu'il lisait la
presse chaque matin pour apprendre ce
qu'il pensait même si c'était faux
une entrée en matière pour 2020 alors
bon il côté l'année dernière emmanuel
macron renoue donc avec cette tradition
ses voeux à la presse à l'elysée le chef
de l'état qui a évoqué on vient de voir
plusieurs sujets pendant cette
allocution peut-être pour recréer du
lien avec les journalistes pour un
communiqué pour rassurer avec peut-être
aussi en ligne de mire la présidentielle
de 2022 c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
mais côté didier maïsto président de sud
radio bonsoir didier mais l'essentiel
est là
guy konopnicki journaliste à marianne
merci à vous également d'être là alors
emmanuel macron finalement qui est un
peu changé d'avis je ne sais pas si vous
serez d'accord avec cette analyse ou
c'est bien plus stratégique évidemment
il ya un an
voilà il voulait discuter directement
avec les français sans passer par les
journalistes qui a eu lieu le grand
débat et puis là tout d'un coup il dit
voilà le début du quinquennat a nourri
des malentendus et il s'exprime devant
la presse
sartre a au pédalage stratégique guy
konopnicki oui c'est dire que d'une
manière générale il a découvert les
corps d'un terme les corps
intermédiaires c'est dire que j'ai une
bouche loin il ya les syndicats
on pensait faire toutes les réformes en
passant par dessus laisse indifférent à
ces ratés quand même ça ne marche pas
mais la même chose aussi avec les élus
les élus locaux
alors on
on a vu pendant la crise et le gros de
la crise de gilet jaune et aller vers
les mers il était allé vers l'est il
avait besoin d'eux pour organiser son
débat il vient vers les journalistes
moi je pense qu'il a commencé par un
nous plaît qui est très grave
mes yeux c'est que c'est un anniversaire
que nous n'avons pas pu célébrer à sa
juste mesure en raison des
manifestations il ya cinq ans douze
collaborateurs d'un journal tombés dans
leur rédaction
à charlie hebdo je pense que présentant
ses voeux à la presse le président de la
république devait parler de la liberté
de la presse et rendent hommage à ceux
qui sont tombés pour elle
est ce que je trouve significatif c'est
qu'un peu plus loin quand il parle alors
vous dit des choses très bien on espère
que ce soit vis des suivis d'effet sur
notre conception du droit d'auteur sur
les gens d'ailleurs il cite et il dit
vous êtes auteur journalistes ou
photographes dessinateurs
je présente dessinateur 1 il y à des
dessinateurs chênois marianne c'est un
des mois de 1 des votes d'expression
important mais voilà il ya les
dessinateurs tombé il ya cinq ans dont
l'un était à charlie et à marianne mais
peu importe les quatre qui compte
évidemment c'est quand même oublier ça
dans la liste des professions qui font
la presse
c'est une amie sur vous c'est une
omission d'aujourd'hui c'est maîtrisé
c'est des gens qui lisent les journaux
qui aiment les journaux n'oublie pas ça
et là on a cette culture technocratique
où on lit là on lit pas la presse ont
ils les notes de ses collaborateurs
des années qui lui arrive ça y est les
collaborateurs bien avant d'être
président quand il était ministre quand
il était à l'elysée auprès d'ol land ces
genres et à leur bureau et puis il ya le
petit bloc qui est légal et les articles
choisis
jadis découpe est aujourd'hui sorti sur
imprimante
voilà ce que vous devez savoir
aujourd'hui mais cette relation avec le
journal et die des pics à s'amarrer
incroyable qui est cette omission
effectivement ça dit quelque chose
guy qu'on a affronté le relevé à juste
titre ça paraît effectivement incroyable
qui est pas une mention sur ses
confrères à tuer s'est dit quelque chose
d' emmanuel macron qui est quelqu'un
effectivement qui découvre la vie dans
les notes quand on a l'odeur du papier
quand on a attaché charnellement
pratiquement un journal quand on sait
qu'en france on peut mourir pour faire
un dessin une caricature et que c'est
complètement biffés au mit pas cité dans
le discours du président de la
république
évidemment c'est une première chose qui
est choquant d'ailleurs ici ce soir nous
n'existons pas puisque si j'ai bien
suivi du président la république il ya
une presse professionnelle qui a une
imprimatur je note qui crt ont fait un
acte courageux et séditieux puisque rt
même s'il n'a pas cité la russie il l'a
quand même évoqué puisqu'il a parlé de
manipulation c'est bien ce que ça veut
dire pendant la campagne présidentielle
donc aujourd'hui finalement ils essaient
de s'appuyer sur des gens qui sont assez
docile qui l'ont fait élire qu'ils ont
mis en une de tous les magazines qui ne
se rebelle pas beaucoup et j'aurais bien
aimé un hommage à tous les vidéastes
amateurs parce qu'ils les avaient
balayés comme ça il les a nommé prise et
il les a niées
il les a insultés ça fait un an plus
d'un an il en a plutôt parlé ensemble
méfiance j'ai été bien plus user on va
en disant c'est pas avec un téléphone
portable messi ou étaient les
journalistes men cim qui a pris des
risques qui s'est pris des tirs de l bd
qui s'est pris des gaz lacrymogènes et
des grenades j ai liquidés des crosnes
hadj ali
f4 certainement pas les journalistes
mènent suivre les journalistes mme anne
sweeney arrivé le matin il disait à
personne il repartait le soir il s est
violent voilà ce qui s'appelle justement
il a fait mention à tous ces deux
éléments au début de son discours on va
l'écouter 1 il a tenu à rappeler que
lors des manifestations du gilet jaune
auquel vous faites allusion les journées
nice avait été protégé par les forces de
l'ordre apparemment vous n'avez pas
assez rappelé aux vieux important de
réguler réglementé on va écouter nous ne
devons pas être fermé par principe à ce
que de grands acteurs économiques y
compris étrangers investissent dans la
presse française
il est des titres pour lesquels cela
fonctionne parfaitement
nous devons veiller en revanche à ce que
toutes les garanties soit au rendez-vous
pour protéger le pluralisme de
l'information l'indépendance des
rédactions et finalement défendre cette
presse souveraine et libre qui est la
marque des grandes nations en 2019 la
loi bichet a été modifié en ce sens de
sorte que les sociétés de distribution
de puissent être contrôlés à plus de 20%
par les intérêts étrangers non
communautaires dans la même lignée grâce
à un décret du ministre de l'économie
publié le 1er janvier la presse est
désormais est plus dans le contrôle des
investissements étrangers ce qui
implique un régime d'autorisation
préalable est très protecteur et quel
que soit le statut des investisseurs
continueront à veiller à l'indépendance
journalistique et à éviter toute forme
de concentration qui viendraient
justement mettre en péril cette
indépendance et je suis sûr que des
débats continueront de voir le jour dans
les prochains mois sur ce sujet qui nous
amèneront collectivement à poursuivre la
réflexion et de travail des journalistes
au moment de la crise dite des filets
jaunes ont été protégés par les forces
de l'ordre parce qu'ils étaient
journalistes
et je ne vous ai pas entendu le rappeler
je pense que c'est important de d'abord
c'est cette clarification et c'est bien
normal dans une démocratie mais ça veut
dire que nombre de nos concitoyens alors
considéré que les journalistes étaient
devenus des ennemis parce qu'il ne
disait pas ce que voulait entendre
ou que ne disait pas une vérité qui
était la leur au sel qu'ils partageaient
sur leurs réseaux sociaux preuve s'il en
est toutefois que toutes les
informations ne se valent pas parce
qu'elles n'ont pas forcément toutes le
statut d'information je reviendrai sur
ce sujet ce qui veut bien dire que
quelque part il faut réguler ou
réglementé et d'ailleurs votre
profession a toujours vécu dans la
régulation réglementation qu'il s'agisse
de la liberté elle-même comme du modèle
économique
enlevez la régulation pardon de le dire
il n'y a plus un titre une chaîne
présent qui existent donc ne vous
trompez pas à combattre peut-être trop
rapidement toute forme de régulation
historiquement elle vous a protégé et le
continuera de le faire et le sujet que
j'évoque est un sujet de protection
indique guy maisto ça doit vous faire
plaisir à ses deux sorties
disons que nous ne vivons pas dans le
même pays
moi ce que j'ai vu parce que peut-être
je suis pas sûr les ors de la république
mais plutôt que de partir en week-end ou
à la mongie jeu le week end je suis avec
les gens dans la rue pour voir ce qui
s'y passe donc bien sûr qu'il ya
quelques policiers qui ont protégé des
journalistes au début des actes d gilet
jaune parce que les jours les gilets
jaunes étaient furieux de voir toutes
ces fausses d'informations divulguées à
la fois sur la manière de se comporter
les forces de l'ordre sur le comptage de
des manifestants ou encore sur le fait
d'être affublé de tous les maux de la
terre antisémites racistes homophobes
j'en passe et des meilleurs tout ça par
les journalistes mènent suit mais les
éditorialistes les plus en vue ou les
pseudo philosophe les simili philosophe
pour reprendre la terminologie de
monsieur le président de la république
moi j'ai surtout vu des journalistes
indépendants embarqué par les forces de
l'ordre c'est encore arrivé à rémy
buisine
il ya quelques jours j'ai vu un certain
nombre de journalistes violentes et des
journalistes américains des débats des
joueurs non c'est pas ça non mais s'est
blessé
vous m'interrogez et l'emballage orange
elle agit sur la sur la séquence
on nous ne vivons pas manifestement dans
le même pays
guy konopnicki pour sur la régulation
justement sur
sur la régulation on a toujours vécu
avec un encadrement légal transgresser
c'est à dire que la presse qui est
longtemps régie par les ordonnances 44
de 1944 qui interdisent la constitution
de groupes nous aviez le groupe hersant
groupe lagardère et s'appuie donc de
toutes façons on avait des goûts ensuite
les investisseurs étrangers
on investit à l'étranger communautaire
pas communautaire n'a rien fait partie
de l'ensemble de journaux dans lequel 1
1 nous avons à l'investisseur un
investisseur tchèque depuis les
communautaires tout où l'avion né dans
la commune dans la communauté européenne
je crois que le problème de la
dépendance n'est pas et de
l'indépendance de la presse n'est pas
forcément le l'origine de deux
investisseurs qu'ils soient italiens
tchèques anglais ou ou qui viennent ou
qui viennent de plus loin c'est son
activité or nous avons eu quand même un
rapport un peu fort entre nous avons
toujours des investisseurs qui dépendent
de l'état d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est ça est ce qu'ils sont dans dans la
construction dans l'armement
à cela sont des investisseurs français
de déroule dans lequel il ya de très
bons journaux et des rédactions qui se
battent défendre leur indépendance de
l'ena détruit mais nous avons quand même
toujours eu une question à dire mais le
débat effectivement c'est celui ci c'est
sûrement parce que c'est une sont ni les
investisseurs riches ni les
investisseurs extracommunautaire eaux
communautaires c2 qui dépend leur
fortune de qui dépensent ils sont ils en
affaires publiques avec l'état si vous
vendez d'été les dodgers et les moyens
de pression c'est que ce désert des
dunes fait des travaux publics ou
vendait des deux vous voulez de la
téléphonie c'est très compliqué ensuite
de s'absoudre et d'être et de se dire
indépendant la vraie indépendance comme
disait l'autre consiste à savoir des
clients dépendent ce qui en dépend
ce qui complique les choses c'est que
nous sommes dans un système multimédia
ou donc on va trouver et bat tous les
opérateurs de téléphonie on va trouver
qui sont effectivement tous dans tous
dans l'audiovisuel puisque aujourd'hui
le lien entre l'audiovisuel et le
numérique le portable car là c'est là
qu'il faut travailler c'est là que le
législateur doit travailler à concerter
la profession comprendre comment ça se
passe et comment on peut défendre
l'indépendance de l'information
l'indépendance du journalisme dans un
monde numérique qui est dominé par trois
quatre cinq multinationales et avec des
groupes français avec ça c'est la vraie
question la république d'ailleurs il
voulait un conseil de déontologie des
médias l'on se rend compte que je me
trompe pas en disant que même les médias
les grands médias français leur tour
tourne le dos à ce conseil un le nom
mais s'il voulait se contrôler soi même
c'est toujours un petit peu compliqué
les ordres professionnels on se pensait
bien kwassa kwassa abouti premièrement
deuxièmement si le posant la république
veut une presse indépendante
l'indépendance à se décrète pas
l'indépendance ça se vérifie qu'ils
laissent les médias tranquille et puis
il ya le jugement des lecteurs des
internautes et téléspectateurs des
auditeurs en fait qu'ils achètent les
médias on avait seulement qu'aux débuts
voilà il cette histoire d'un conseil de
conseil de déontologie
on n'est ni avocat ni médecin ni jeu
je n'ai pas moi à contrôler la
déontologie des confrères si je pense
que un article n'est pas bon dans le
figaro mais je lui réponds donc fait
attendre on jouera lé c'est c'est comme
ça que ça se passe
l'animateur j'étais président de la
société des réacteurs à une époque à
marianne la déontologie ça se contrôle
de l'intérieur avec un système qui est
assez répandu dans beaucoup de titres tu
celui des sociétés des rédacteurs par
exemple et il y en a d'autres
il ya d'autre systèmes il y à des
endroits où il ya un médiateur
déontologue ceci c'est la faire de
chaque entreprise
ça n'est pas ne pas être à faire dans un
espèce de truc tuyau de poêle existe des
signes et comment il y aura des
représentants de l'état y aura ou alors
des idées si c'est si c'est un vote mais
alors on fait comment mais pour résumer
à t-il dit aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est
important pour bien comprendre l'essence
la nature du discours les tenants et les
aboutissants il a dit finalement il ya
des journalistes professionnels quand
une carte professionnelle etc
je leur donne mon imprimatur et je leur
ai demandé de réfléchir il a dit un
employé le nous nous allons organiser
l'indépendance
déjà c'est suspect quand on est quand on
est censé être un contre-pouvoir d'avoir
l'exécutif l'elysée qui vous dit nous
allons organiser votre indépendance
moi je pars mon premier réflexe c'est de
partir en courant voulez j'ai pas besoin
de l'état pour qu'il me dise comment je
dois écrire comment je dois penser
qu'elle doit fait mes auditeurs et sait
déjà c'est un problème des diamants nos
risques on les prend on les prend nos
risques on embauche des gens on investit
on se défend ce matin midi et soir et on
a le jugement du public
que voulez-vous de plus et si les gens
ne sont pas contents il ya une loi qui
est très bien
elle est perfectible tellement 78 180
vols à relire
on est passé d'un contrôle a priori
préventif à une répression a posteriori
pénale c'est à dire qu'on peut se
défendre
c'est à dire qu'on puisse qu'il peut y
avoir une exception de vérité on peut
ça suffit pourquoi deux jours m entre la
justice et les citoyens des organismes
soit disant indépendants qui vont dicter
le bon le mauvais le bien et le mal
c'est une dérive très intérieure c'est
incroyable et une dérive très intérieur
à l'élection des manuels macron présenté
en gestion à l'intérieur six ans fils et
installer des hautes autorités à la fin
du débat est ce que vous vous avez
quelques années de métier est ce que il
ya vraiment une spécificité des
relations journalistes presse en tout
cas président avec le président
maquereau ou c'est pas forcément le cas
écoutez il ya des mutations apprécier
une époque où les journaux de juger rien
de plus important que d'avoir quelqu'un
qui ne lâche pas le président de la
république bon et donc c'est c'est eh on
se battait pour les places dans les
voyages non je m'inclus pas le temps ou
un personnel parce que je suspect battu
pour ça j'ai au contraire invités mais
bon on se battait les journaux pour
avoir les places les bonnes places dans
les avions présidentiels les avions du
premier ministre dans les voyages t'as
pas tellement pour le but du voyage et
l'endroit qu'on allait qu'on allait
visiter mais mais mais pour écouter les
confidences pour parler de ça bon je
crois que ce temps là et est un peu fini
d'abord parce que les informations vont
vraie fausse bonne mauvaise mais de
toute façon elles vont beaucoup plus
vite et donc il ya des choses qu'on sait
perdre
et aussi parce que il y a un état
d'esprit qui a changé chez journalistes
et en bien
de ce point de vue qui était l'idée am
il faut absolument répercuter penser en
avant la phrase qu'il insistait
d'ailleurs sur l'ironie de mots
l'utilisait je vais dire je vais dire ce
que je pense quand j'ouvre le jaune le
matin est souvent question je suis pas
d'accord ça c'est une c'est un autre
temps de le nôtre à beaucoup d'autres
défauts mais ça c'est plutôt en train de
passer des espèces de journalistes de
lui le prétendu fréquentant les milieux
bien informés
[Musique]
l'armée semble tellement mal informés
effectivement si vous voulez faire
vraiment moi j'ai pas de leçon à donner
mais on eu d'expérience c'est pas dans
les conférences de presse
c'est pas dans les cocktails ce n'est
pas dans les avions présidentiels ce
n'est pas dans les chambres d'hôtel ce
n'est pas en vacances n'est pas au
théâtre avec des hommes politiques
fusse-t-il célèbre et en vue que vous
allez faire votre boulot de journaliste
nous on aime je suis invité à tous je ne
vais rien vous ne verrez jamais dans un
cocktail vous ne verrez jamais dans une
dans une mondanité et c'est parce que je
veux garder d'abord mon indépendance
mon libre arbitre ma capacité à
critiquer dans le bon sens comme dans le
mauvais si je copine c'est fini c'est
quoi cette histoire d'abord lundi matin
pour aller glaner ici la désinformation
vous savez très bien quand on fait des
enquêtes ça marche pas comme ça mais je
sais et c'est pas comme ça le piège
parce que si vous pensez qu'un homme
politique va vous donner un scoop en off
et c'est un homme politique il est dans
sa stratégie
il veut être réélu il veut briller de
suiveux plaire etc
si on aime ça c'est de la communication
c'est vrai du jourdain ouest et la
différence elle est là et cet exercice
compassée de la conférence de presse de
presse à l'elysée il est vraiment qu'on
passait sans mauvais jeu de mots parce
que c'est pas là qu'il était dans la
séduction aujourd'hui manuel macron vous
l'avez trouvé justement est ce qu'il
renoue finalement celui qui voulait
et sas qui les retomber là-dedans ce
côté se refaire une image vis-à-vis des
journalistes dont il aura certainement
besoin bientôt un an ça déjà me ça a
déjà marché
ceci dit vous trouvez obama avant son
élection ça a marché
oui mais là vous voyez le nombre le
nombre de u 9 un nombre de reportages
c'est ce qui a marché peut remarcher non
notre pression est tellement dos ils ont
marché jusqu'à marché quand même c'était
la nouveauté on a assisté un spectacle
extravagant qui était l'effondrement
simultané des deux partis politiques qui
a alterné au pouvoir depuis 1981 alors
la vente puisque les autres étaient là
avant son revenu non on à l'effondrement
simultané et il ya ce personnage qui
monte qui brusquement il aimerait bien
c'est pas la génération cette année non
c'était pas les plans du réseau
évidemment organisé évident avec une
conférence de passe toute la journée sur
sur france info et tous les toutes les
15 minutes il va parler attention il va
par les roulements de tambour il a parlé
voilà ce qu'il a dit dans l'autre sens
ça s'est moins bien fini donc d'abord ça
a marché mais ça a marché dans un
contexte qui n'est pas celui
exclusivement de la communication c'est
un contexte politique alors qu'elle sera
là et quel sera le quel est le contexte
politique aujourd'hui quel sera-t-il au
lendemain des municipales
qu'est ce qui ne sera quand on sera dans
la dernière ligne droite de l'élection
présidentielle que les candidatures sont
déclarés j'en sais rien j'en sais rien
n'y fit rien personne ne sait quel sera
le mot de la fin merci messieurs didier
ledoux et guy konopnicki d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france et
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour 1
point trompé sur l'actualité
[Musique]
oui
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
jean froid et loïc deux frères
aventuriers ont décidé de suivre le
cours du troisième plus grand fleuve du
monde les yangzi notre objectif est
simple aller à la rencontre d'un fleuve
mythique qui telle une artère irrigue le
pays le plus peuplé au monde
[Musique]
en cinq mois de sa source sur les hauts
plateaux tibétains à son embouchure à
shanghai ils ont parcouru plus de 7000
km à moto et en tricycle à la découverte
du lien qui unit l'homme à l'eau
[Musique]
nous filons à toute allure vers de
nouvelles rencontres et des paysages qui
sans aucun doute vont encore beaucoup
nous surprendre chaque jour en politique
des milliers de parties d'échecs sont
joués mais les règles ne sont pas
toujours respectées les couleurs
changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois de
fine stratégie peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
monsieur les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
votre lecture de juristes sur le système
japonais je peux dire que le système
judiciaire japonais est inique que dit
carlos ghosn hier dans sa conférence de
presse il explique qu'en réalité ses
avocats le japonais bien sûr ne pouvait
pas lui garantir un procès équitable
c'est dit est ce que cette affaire là
son évasion ne rend pas service quelque
part au japon
franchement j'y crois pas trop parce
qu'il ya quand même l'effet négatif
c'est à dire je dirais l'humiliation
mais quelque part le départ de carlos
ghosn
indiscutablement leur rend service parce
que cette hypothèque sur l'honneur d'une
justice consistant à ce qu'un procès
soit en réalité l'expression d'une
décision politique
celle d honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
velimir poutine désigne le patron du
fisc russe au mur elle met sous steam
comme nouveau premier ministre une
nomination prennant surprise de la
démission du gouvernement de dmitri
medvedev une demande de changement
hébergé au sein de la société selon le
président russe
meigneux macron qui renoue avec la
tradition il a présenté aujourd'hui ses
voeux à la presse à l'elysée le chef
d'état a évoqué plusieurs sujets dans
cette allocution protection des sources
sécurité des journalistes ou bien encore
réforme de l'audiovisuel public
nouvelle journée interprofessionnelle de
grèves et manifestations prévues demain
et le 24 janvier
on a appris ce soir et mène mais promet
lui de continuer à expliquer concertée
la réforme des retraites sixième semaine
de mobilisation
un rassemblement de fonctionnaires a eu
lieu devant le ministère des finances à
paris manifestation également de la
police scientifique et des travailleurs
portuaires
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
en direct sur rt france en russie et
mirel me faustin a donc accepté le poste
de premier ministre après la démission
du gouvernement de mitry medvedev avec
la démission de tout le gouvernement
dmitri medvedev a dit vouloir donner au
président les moyens de prendre toutes
les mesures qui s'imposent
fanny routine a remercié ce dernier pour
son travail plus de précision avec notre
forêt de contes antoine cléroux à moscou
c'est donc mirail michou steen qui va
succéder à dimitri medvedev au poste de
premier ministre
âgé de 53 ans et inconnu du grand public
il était depuis 2010 à la tête du
service fédéral des impôts cette
nomination intervient après une journée
riche en rebondissements lors de son
adresse annuelle devant l'assemblée
fédérale l'a dit mir poutine a proposé
plusieurs réformes plusieurs amendements
à apporter à la constitution des
amendements qui donnerait davantage de
pouvoirs au parlement tout de suite
après ce discours le premier ministre
dimitri medvedev s'est entretenu avec le
président vladimir poutine et à l'issue
de cette rencontre dimitri medvedev a
présenté la démission de tout son
gouvernement
vous aussi chers collègues vous avez
tous été témoins du message du président
de la fédération de russie vladimir
vladimirovitch en tant que président a
non seulement fixer les priorités du
travail dans notre pays pour l'année à
venir mais a également décrit un certain
nombre de changements fondamentaux et
dans la constitution de la fédération de
bruxelles ces changements lorsqu'ils
seront adoptées et selon toute
probabilité cela se fera après une
discussion comme cela a été dit
apporteront des modifications
importantes non seulement un certain
nombre d'articles de la constitution
mais aussi dans l' équilibre du pouvoir
dans son ensemble au sein du pouvoir
exécutif pouvoir législatif et pouvoir
judiciaire dans ce contexte il est
évident que nous en tant que
gouvernement de la fédération de russie
ont donné au président de notre pays la
possibilité de prendre toutes les
décisions nécessaires à cet effet et
dans ces conditions je pense qu'il
serait juste que conformément à
l'article 117 de la constitution de la
fédération de russie
le gouvernement de la fédération de
russie dans sa composition actuelle
démissionne je remercie bien entendu
ceux qui ont participé au travail du
gouvernement et dans cette composition
et bien sûr les décisions suivantes
seront prises par le président du pays
et ce en réponse vladimir poutine a dit
prendre acte de cette décision et
remercié son premier ministre sortant a
c'est que tous ces ministres pour tous
les efforts fournis pour ma part je
voudrais aussi vous remercier pour tout
ce qui a été fait durant cette étape de
notre travail commun je voudrais
exprimer ma satisfaction quant aux
résultats obtenus
bien sûr tout n'a pas réussi mais il
n'est jamais possible de tout faire dans
son intégralité
j'espère que nous verrons prochainement
je rencontrerai chacun d'entre vous et
vous demande d'assumer vos fonctions
dans leur intégralité jusqu'à la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
[Musique]
entre la promesse de réformes
constitutionnelles la démission soudaine
du gouvernement et la nomination tout
aussi rapide d'un nouveau premier
ministre
c'est donc une nouvelle page du pouvoir
exécutif qui s'ouvre en russie et c'est
donc michel michaut sting qui remplace
dmitri medvedev au poste de premier
ministre russe mais qui est cet inconnu
du grand public avant sa nomination le
point sur son parcours en images
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
[Musique]
une annonce surprise après le discours
annuel du chef de l'état devant les
députés et sénateurs russes allocution
devant l'assemblée fédérale qui réunit
les deux chambres du parlement
au menu la question la démographie et la
volonté de mettre en place une nouvelle
politique familiale la lumière continue
également proposé une série de réformes
constitutionnelles soumises à un
référendum sur le sujet on écoute alexeï
popikov sénateur russe poutine réfléchir
au système politique qui va fonctionner
en russie pendant les dernières années 2
de sa présidence et après sa présidence
et je pense qu'il est venu à la
conclusion que il faut procéder une ce
que j'appellerais une démocratisation du
pouvoir présidentiel en russie
ça ne veut pas dire que le président va
être destitué de ses pouvoirs et devenir
une personne à l'été honoraires comme
dans quelques pays acp
le président on va toujours conservé 2
prérogatives assez importante mais il
doit compter plus avec le parlement et
le gouvernement parce que d'après les
propositions de monsieur poutine
le parlement va
décider qui sera le premier ministre et
qui seront et quelle sera la formation
du cabinet donc ça sera un système
mélanger alors qu'est ce que révèle
cette démission sur la stratégie
politique à venir de vladimir poutine
c'est ce que nos invités ont essayé de
décrypter ce soir alors cette démission
finalement est la résultante de dut
finalement d'une demi surprise la
situation économique est mauvaise on est
dans une logique où le président va
nuire poutine l'a rappelé devant
l'assemblée fédérale il veut se
concentrer sur les maux qui grèvent le
développement économique de la russie la
pression démographique une anémie
économique la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
et puis bien évidemment des résultats
électoraux de son propre parti russie
unie qui ne sont pas très bons en tout
cas si on prend le dernier test
électoral les élections municipales de
septembre 2019 c'est une évolution
logique
je pense qu'il ya eu différentes phases
dans l'histoire récente de la russie
depuis l'arrivée de l'ère poutine
la première période ça a été de remettre
en place des institutions d'appliquer la
constitution dans toutes les ventes ou
de l'est sujet de la fédération de
russie
la deuxième étape qui était à peu près
par à l'aise c'était le redressement de
l'économie russe et aujourd'hui on est
finalement dans et bien le l'ultime
étape qui est la modernisation de la
russie
économiquement et la redistribution de
la richesse dans l'ensemble des régions
russes pour pousser jusqu'au bout et
bien ces réformes qui sont qui sont
nécessaires c'est quand même plus qu'une
nuance à montrent que la russie
maintenant elle est beaucoup plus stable
plus assuré et poutine prépare
finalement l'après poutine pour entrer
dans l'histoire comme l'homme qui a
stabilisé la russie qu'il a unifié et
qui lui fait progresser dont le don dans
une voie démocratique à la russe bien
sûr et donc qui devrait couper à mon
sens beaucoup de critiques en disant
c'est un régime autocratique
présidentielle donc c'est pour moi un
pas important et que je qualifierais
d'historique
emmanuel mec - présenté ses voeux à la
presse cet après midi après avoir boudé
l'exercice l'année dernière l'occasion
pour le chef de l'état de sortir un peu
plus du silence en plein mouvement
social ont fait le point sur le discours
avec notre reporter katia technique lors
de ses voeux et voyait le maquereau a
tenu à rassurer la profession notamment
sur son avenir économique en évoquant un
plan de filière et une protection face
aux géants du numérique a assuré
également sur le pluralisme
dia la liberté de presse ou encore la
liberté de blasphémer et puis il a
assuré qu'il recevrait les liens avec
les journalistes envers lesquels vous
savez il a tenu souvent des propos très
durs des mots incompréhensibles selon le
président de l'association de la presse
présidentielle qui a inauguré les voeux
il a posé une question une série de
questions au président emmanuel macron
s'est alors livré à un exercice assez
déconcertant il a éludé certaines
questions
il a contourné les critiques pour
parfois répond de manière assez
lapidaire c'était le cas avec la
question posée sur les violences
policières sur les journalistes durant
les manifestations
il a plutôt évoqué la question du
maintien de l'ordre de la violence de
rue du fait que des forces de l'ordre
avaient souvent protégés des
journalistes pour enfin répondre à la
question posée
je vous propose de l'écouter il ya eu
dans le cadre des il y a dans le cadre
des manifestations
en effet des violences dans lesquelles
les journalistes ont pu être prises à
partie et non pas parfois pas pu faire
le travail comme il se devait et vous en
avez rappelé les termes et je les
condamne avec la même clarté et de la
même manière qu'eux il importe de
rappeler l'indispensable travail dans
une démocratie que font les forces de
l'ordre qui sont au service de l'ordre
public et du respect de la loi
il importe d'exiger le respect de toute
la déontologie et d'exemplarité
c'est pour ça que j'ai demandé aussi des
propositions précises au ministre de
l'intérieur sur ce sujet et je souhaite
aussi d'ailleurs que au delà du dialogue
qui a commencé avec votre profession
pour clarifier sécuriser le cadre
d'intervention dans les manifestations
celui ci puisse encore être amélioré
pour qu aucune dérive ne soit possible
et que tous les journalistes qui sont
dans le cadre d'un événement quel qu'il
soit soit protégé de la violence et
puissent faire leur travail comme ils
doivent le faire
emmanuel macron a également répondu à
une question sur la loi contre les faits
que nous qui inquiète les journalistes
selon lui la loi qui régit
seulement la profession n'est pas assez
robuste il faut de nouveaux outils mais
il a conseillé de ne pas s'inquiéter
puisque le juge contrôlera et verra au
bout un processus démocratique et le
président français s'est livré une leçon
de journalisme face au parterre
d'invités
il a dit que ce n'était pas au
gouvernement de décider qu'ils étaient
journalistes et qu'ils ne l'étaient pas
mais bien à nous et il a exhorté à
pourchasser les faux journalistes les
journalistes citoyens les autoproclamés
vidéaste blogueurs selon lui ce sont eux
la véritable menace de la profession
alors que cette question ne lui était
pas posée je vous propose de l'écouter
je pense pas que ce soit au gouvernement
de dire qui est journaliste qui ne l'est
pas quel est le statut de l'information
et cetera je n'ai jamais pensé cela et
je ne crois pas que ce soit une voie
dans laquelle nous ayons collectivement
à nous engager
mais je suis convaincu d'une chose c'est
que la société du commentaire permanent
n'est pas la société de l'information
et c'est que la multiplication des
auteurs possibles de traces ou de simili
journalistique est une menace pour votre
profession et pour la démocratie
il faut un moment quelqu'un pour pouvoir
dire d'où vient cette trace quel est son
statut qu'il a authentifié dans quel
contexte l été et pouvoir la qualifier
c'est la base de votre travail
mais si quiconque émettant depuis son
téléphone portable peut se considérer
comme journaliste vous permet de vous
dire que dans la base déontologique la
vocation même l'existence même de votre
profession la capacité à tenir dans la
durée sera difficile emmanuel macron a
conclu ses voeux en assurant qu'il
allait accorder davantage d'entretiens
aux journalistes qui s'étaient plaints
d'avoir trop peu de contacts avec la
présidence et en même temps il a débuté
ses voeux
par une pique envers la profession en
paraphrasant le général de gaulle
il a expliqué qu'il lisait la presse
chaque matin pour apprendre ce qu'il
pensait même si c'était faux une bonne
entrée en matière pour 2020 et nos
confrères journalistes nous ont donné
leur point de vue sur le discours du
chef de l'état écoutez moi je pense
qu'il a commencé par un loup play qui
est très grave
mes yeux c'est que c'est un anniversaire
que nous n'avons pas pu célébrer à sa
juste mesure en raison des
manifestations il ya cinq ans douze
collaborateurs d'un journal tomberait
dans leur rédaction
à charlie hebdo je pense que présentant
ses voeux à la presse le président de la
république devait parler de la liberté
de la presse et rendent hommage à ceux
qui sont tombés pour elle quand on sait
qu'en france on peut mourir pour faire
un dessin une caricature et que c'est
complètement biffés au mit pas cité dans
le discours du président de la
république
évidemment c'est une première chose qui
est choquant d'ailleurs ici ce soir nous
n'existons pas puisque si j'ai bien
suivi du président la république il ya
une presse professionnelle qui a une
imprimatur jeunes autistes irt ont fait
un acte courageux et séditieux puisque
rt
même s'il n'a pas cité la russie il l'a
quand même évoqué puisqu'il a parlé de
manipulation c'est bien ce que ça veut
dire pendant la campagne présidentielle
donc aujourd'hui finalement ils essaient
de s'appuyer sur des gens qui sont assez
docile qui l'ont fait élire qu'ils ont
mis en une de tous les magazines qui ne
se rebelle pas beaucoup et j'aurais bien
aimé un hommage à tous les vidéastes
amateurs parce qu'il les a balayées
comme ça il a méprisé
il les a niées il les a insultés
avec quarante deuxième journée
consécutive de grève contre la réforme
des retraites demain une nouvelle grande
journée d'action interprofessionnelle
est aussi prévue pour continuer de
réclamer le retrait du projet
l'intersyndicale annonce une nouvelle
journée de grèves et de manifestations
interprofessionnelles le 24 janvier
prochain
écoutez le premier ministre à l'occasion
d'un séminaire gouvernemental
la grève à la ratp la grève à la sncf me
paraissait sans issue et qu'elle n'avait
que trop duré depuis des cendres nous
sommes restés constants et fermes sur la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
nous avons veillé à trouver et à
proposer des transitions longue dans les
entreprises publiques de transport
conformément à ce à quoi nous nous
étions engagés très tôt dans le
processus de réflexion sur la mise en
place de ce système universal de
retraite les propositions que nous avons
formulées permettent de dessiner le
respect des parcours individuels et des
attentes légitimes mais nous avons fait
ces propositions et je pense qu'il est
temps de sortir par le haut et
organisations syndicales de la fonction
publique se sont rassemblées à midi
devant le ministère des finances à paris
à l'appel notamment de la cgt fo fsu et
sud notre reporter ni la fameuse ou
étaient sur place ils étaient entre 150
et 200 personnes rassemblées ici devant
bercy parmi les manifestants
principalement des salariés de la
fonction publique des enseignants des
agents de la ratp ou encore du personnel
de santé qui étaient là pendant deux
heures pour discuter des prochaines
actions à mener pour poursuivre ce bras
de fer qui est engagé depuis
quarante-deux jours maintenant
avec le gouvernement je proposais les
écouter il était important pour nous de
montrer la détermination des
fonctionnaires et nous sommes là dans un
rassemblement militant devant bercy
parce que bercy
il était important qu'on soit là c'est
là où se négocie énormément de dossiers
dont celui
i de la catégorie active pour les
hospitaliers que je représente
aujourd'hui parce que je suis là au
titre de la fédération des services
publics et de santé force ouvrière pour
les hospitaliers et territoriaux de
france et donc il était important qu'on
soit là pour montrer notre détermination
à continuer le mouvement malgré les de
cette mobilisation qui dure depuis
quarante deux jours maintenant les
annonces du premier ministre concernent
que la chevaux qui est un des éléments
de cette réforme
ce qu'il ya de malheureux c'est que il
faudrait que tous les salariés de france
soit dans la rue parce qu'on va tous
prendre plein la tête qu'on soit du
privé ou du public
il suffit simplement c'est mathématique
un calcul des pensions de retraite qui
est sûre calculé sur l'ensemble de la
carrière et non pas sur les meilleurs
mois de salaire forcément c'est
mathématique
le montant de la retraite ou de la
pension pour la fonction publique sera
inférieur à ce qu'il est actuellement et
malgré la volonté du gouvernement de
trouver une issue à cette crise les
manifestants restent déterminés ils
demandent le retrait pur et simple de la
réforme des retraites est le port du
havre bloquée pendant au moins trois
jours pour réclamer le retrait du projet
de réforme des retraites les
travailleurs portuaires font grève
depuis ce mardi ont fait le point avec
les la sarraf avec pierre pissavy
yvernault une nouvelle opération
portmore lancer une action à
l'initiative de la fédération nationale
cgt des ports et docks ce afin de
pénaliser l'activité
la semaine dernière déjà le port de
france avait été paralysé pendant trois
jours pour les mêmes revendications déjà
d'une sueur sur l'âge plus sur le départ
à la retraite à 64 ans la pénibilité on
a un métier où ou
on est déjà à huit en dessous de la
moyenne par rapport au décès sur les
ports français
donc oui c'est clair qu'il ya un impact
conséquent pour pour nous travailleurs
portuaires mais pas mais paul tuquoi les
générations à venir et autres sont
impactés par cette réforme
une action qui n'est pas sans
conséquences pour l'économie locale
les grèves ont commencé début décembre
au moment où certains commerçants font
50 % de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
je pense que les mouvements sociaux ne
sont pas bons à court terme
si on regarde l'activité portuaire on a
des résultats directs avec des escales
annulé je suis aussi soucieuse pour les
commerces qui peuvent en pâtir je suis
aussi inquiète pour la suite pour le
moyen et à long terme 450 travailleurs
portuaires pour un mouvement inédit
depuis 1992
les militants se montre déterminé bien
sûr que on s'est mis d'accord les
instances de la fédération nationale
port et docks cgt se réunit
régulièrement sur paris pour décider des
actions à venir
des actions qui ont eu lieu précédemment
donc
donc oui il ya un an payent et il est
clair on se doit d d'un combat pour se
faire retirer cette réforme qui est
néfaste pour les travailleurs portuaires
et france et français les manifestants
ne compte donc pas s'arrêter là
il prévoit également l'installation de
piquets de grève devant les directions
des grands ports maritimes ce vendredi
hervé dennis rédacteur en chef de port
et corridors se montre lui pessimistes
en écoute j'ai rencontré les
responsables la de la cnpd cgt j'ai
rencontré des responsables des
organisations patronales
ils restent tous en tout campé sur leurs
positions pour le moment on n'a pas
tellement de vision d'avenir l'ailé lé
trafic sncf très perturbée font que les
ports français souffrent énormément ou
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya une sortie
une solution une sortie pour la fnpd il
ya lacunes c'est le retrait du projet
pour les industriels de lacunes c'est
l'arrêt des mouvements et puis peut-être
des négociations mais je pense que
chacun essaye un peu de camper sur ses
positions et honnêtement vu ma chaise
d'observateurs les choses ne vont pas en
s'améliorant très relatif retour au
calme
à fort de france en martinique après les
violents affrontements qui ont opposé
forces de l'ordre militant pour la
justice dans les anciennes colonies
françaises et jeunes gens encagoulés
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi le procès
sous haute tension de cet activiste a
bien lieu mais le jugement est reporté
au 3 juin
cécilia show man
une vingtaine de policiers blessés
quatre interpellations et de nombreuses
dégradations mais aucun chiffre précis
concernant les manifestants le maigre
bilan officiel des événements de ce
début de semaine à fort de france en
traduit l'opacité
selon le récit des témoins c'est la
difficulté d'accès à l'audience à
l'intérieur du tribunal qui aurait mis
le feu aux poudres
en réalité la quantité de gardes mobiles
mobilisées et la lure de certains
manifestants le montre bien
ce procès symbolique à plus d'un titre
était attendu de part et d'autre comme
une occasion de traduire en actes les
tensions qui gangrènent l'île depuis des
années les sept prévenus des militants
anticolonialistes était jugé pour
violences sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique et dégradations
c'était en novembre dernier
depuis octobre il occupe des centres
commerciaux propriété de la première
fortune de l'archipel
le groupe bernard hayot principales
familles békés des antilles autrement
dit les anciens propriétaires d'esclaves
rester aujourd'hui encore principaux
acteurs économiques de lille au mépris
des lois concurrentiel censé garantir la
liberté de commerce
ces activistes exige réparation après le
scandale sanitaire du chlordécone ce
pesticides hautement toxique utilisé par
les planteurs longtemps après son
interdiction officielle et avec
l'assentiment des autorités françaises
mais pas seulement
membre de nombreux collectifs différents
ils ont en commun de refusé
l'appellation militants anti chlordécone
pour une raison simple la famille ayotte
cible de leurs campagnes de
sensibilisation n'est quasiment pas
concernés par ces accusations
d'empoisonnement la banane n'est pas son
activité principale
ce que réclament ses militants la fin du
système colonial
un vaste sujet qui s'étend du choix du
drapeau martiniquais aux réparations
matérielles post esclavage en passant
par la réhabilitation de l'histoire des
anciennes colonies et une refondation
des sociétés dites créole hors du cadre
hérités des siècles passés en raison des
violences le
jugement des sept prévenus attendu ce
lundi au tribunal d'instance est reporté
au 3 juin 2020 d'ici là galvanisé par
les affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre certains militants préparent
déjà leurs futures actions y compris en
france hexagonale la période du carnaval
au mois de mars s'annonce périlleuse la
colère ne retombe pas en iran après le
crash la semaine dernière de l'avion
ukrainien pour le quatrième jour
consécutif les iraniens en colère sont
descendus dans la rue hier est pour
rappel 176 personnes dont de nombreux
étudiants ont été tuées dans l'avion
abattu par erreur téhéran a annoncé
avoir procédé à plusieurs arrestations
il se met un président en roumanie et
appelé à l'unité nationale il a
également réagi à la procédure lancée la
veille par les européens pour
contraindre téhéran à respecter l'accord
sur le nucléaire
les explications de cyrielle benavides
bulbul ans le ton monte entre téhéran et
le rock ce matin à sannois ni ne mâche
pas ces mois les soldats européens
déployés au moyen-orient pourrait être
en danger après que la grande bretagne
la france et l'allemagne et défier
terreau emploiera briser les limites de
son accord nucléaire de 2015
aujourd'hui le soldat américain est en
danger demain le soldat européens
pourraient être en danger
des déclarations qui font suite à la
décision hier de trois pays co
signataire de l'accord de vienne
qui ont lancé le mécanisme de règlement
des différends une procédure pour
contraindre la république islamique à
respecter ses engagements nucléaires au
risque d'un rétablissement des sanctions
de la part de l'onu nous n'avons plus
d'autre choix
étant donné les mesures prises par
l'iran que de faire part aujourd'hui de
nos préoccupations quant au fait que
l'iran ne respecte pas ses engagements
au titre du gie cypihot et et de saisir
la commission conjointe dans le cadre du
mécanisme de règlement des différends
conformément aux dispositions du
paragraphe 36 ipo et ce faisant nos
trois pays ne rejoignent pas la campagne
visant à exercer une pression maximale
contre l'iran nous agissons en toute
bonne foi avec l'objectif primordial de
préserver l'accord et dans l'espoir
sincère de trouver une solution pour
sortir de l'impasse
par le biais d'un dialogue diplomatique
constructif tout en restant dans son
cadre nous espérons ramener l'iran au
plein respect des engagements au titre
du g6 pihouet ce dispositif est soutenu
par les états unis
pour autant l'europe ne souhaite pas
accentuer les sanctions contre téhéran
et entend sauver l'accord sur le
nucléaire c'est la fin de cette édition
prochain journal ce sera demain matin 7h
heure française excellente fin de soirée
sur la terre
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]